What was that sound?
What was that?
That was weird.
Anyway...
Oh, the menu!
Oh my god, it's so loud!
Hold on...
What would it be under?
Oh, pause!
I didn't know you were in here.
Hold on a second...
Welcome to Minecraft!
Give me one second.
Am I late?
No, I just started.
Oh my god.
I looked down and she was sitting.
I didn't know my cat was in here.
She was sitting and meowing at me.
And then I just looked down and she was just laying dead on the floor.
Oh, she's banana.
She's stretching.
Do you have anything you want to say, Pies?
Do you want to say anything?
No?
You're so cute.
Okay, let me let her out real quick.
Save her pitiful life.
She's just a babe.
Maybe she wants to stay.
I can't tell.
Do you want to stay in here?
I can't tell what you want.
I won't be able to let you out later, probably.
Stop looking at me.
What do you want?
Oh my goodness!
She's a stretchy girl!
Nox, thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
And Mike Dyson, thank you for the 10 gifted!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you.
I think I'll just let her out.
Sorry, I didn't realize she was in here.
Okay, give me one second.
Okay, we're good.
Okay.
Dodging Mike Dyson's legal name once more, mint.
Thank you!
Eating Mike Dyson's ass.
Thank you.
Mint, it's my birthday.
Happy birthday, Rail Arm!
Quick one.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Rail Arm.
Oh my god.
Sniper Monkey.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
And 8-bit romance.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Why is everybody gifting?
What was going on?
Okay.
I have to figure out how to turn this down.
Maybe just the master volume.
But...
Oh, that's much better.
Weird logarithm.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Let me turn it up just a little bit more.
75?
Okay, this is better.
For Fox's sake.
Andragos, thank you both.
Thank you for the 5.
Thank you for the 10.
Spank!
What was I saying?
Oh.
I have to tell Heno that I'm ready.
I think.
I'm not ready though.
Oh gosh, you guys.
I'm so nervous.
Is she already on?
Oh.
Oh!
Heno.
Oh my gosh.
You guys!
This is my first time ever playing in the VSHOJO Minecraft server.
If you're unaware, they kind of recently, somewhat recently opened it up to other indie VTubers.
And so, I asked if I could join and check it out.
But there's all sorts of balls.
Balls.
There's all sorts of mods and I don't know.
I don't know at all what they're like.
So.
And of course I'm with Heno.
Later on, Ironmouse might join us as well.
She said maybe in like an hour.
So.
We shall see.
Okay.
I'm just gonna join.
Oh.
Look at...
Who is that?
That's really...
The server is much different than I am at.
Oh!
Oh.
Lange.
Look!
You can see me in the corner!
Why am I on a building?
Where am I?
Why am I up here?
Um.
Your PC is dead.
Oh.
No.
Thank you for the 50 gifted.
Hey there, ghost lady.
Have a stream.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Wow.
Oh.
Wait.
This is crouch.
Why a seat?
Pink concrete.
Brick stairs.
Wait.
Oh.
I'm laying down.
What?
There's like a lay down button.
Oh.
Hello.
Oh, ho, ho.
Thanks for the 50 gifted.
Bye, Roblox.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
I wonder if she is... if she's conscious.
I wonder if she doesn't know that I'm on...
Wait.
What is all this stuff that I have?
Wow!
One of the 90 stuff...
What is this?
I have an uncommon hat grab.
Wait.
No.
Hat grab bag.
I have an info guide.
All of this stuff.
I have a hamburger.
Oh yeah!
I have a candle holder.
Iron staff of building.
A decorative gift.
A warped mailbox.
And a style magazine.
What are those arrows to?
So curious.
Yay, you joined us!
I'm in!
I'm ready!
Henya!
I'm in Minecraft.
Oh!
I'm on top of a building.
Henya, help me.
Why is there another Henya over there?
She found one of the pictures.
What do the pictures do?
Oh wait, this says V-Shojo cat ears.
Can I wear it?
On my hat?
No.
It's just a...
It's just a magazine.
A magazine of...
Wait, right-click to unlock cosmetic.
Oh.
Hello!
Oh, someone else joined.
Someone else joined.
I did try right-clicking it.
This is me right-clicking it.
I'm on a building.
I think there is in-game voice chat, but...
Just in case...
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
What is that?
Oh my god, there's a creature down there.
Okay, it's actually maybe better that I'm up here, because it might kill me.
Oh, in my hand!
Hello?
They disappeared.
Is that Henya?
Mindo?
Henya!
What?
Can you hear me?
She's not in here.
Oh!
Mindo?
Henya!
I'm right here!
Wait, how do I...?
Oh, there she is!
Hello!
Oh.
Wait, you don't know about the voice chat.
Hold on.
Oh, I'm on push-to-talk.
Hello!
Oh, hello!
Wait, I hear your voice from your side though.
Oh, wait.
I think I have to change my microphone.
Okay, that should be good.
Nice!
Oh, you look so cute!
You're so small!
Oh, you can change your height in here.
Wanna change it?
Okay.
How do I change?
This way, this way.
Wait, I don't know how to run.
Oh, now I know.
Okay.
There you go.
What the...?
This way, this way.
She's a mermaid.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I am a mermaid.
I can give you a necklace to turn into the mermaid.
What?
There you go.
Okay.
This is a regular size and you can be a small or bigger.
There you go.
You're bigger now.
Come here, Henya.
I'm gonna squish you.
Come here.
No, no, no.
Like the bug you are.
I can hold you too.
Wait, is this...
Oh, look at you.
You're the same size as me now.
It's the same.
You're so small.
Yeah, it is.
Isn't this...
How do you jump high?
Wait, is this...
You're just short?
Yeah, you're shorter now.
This is the smallest...
I think you're like one block and a little bit.
I'm tiny.
You are.
Wow.
Oh.
Hi, Addy.
Hello.
Oh, hi.
I didn't know you guys were over here.
Hi, y'all.
Hi.
Yeah.
We're streaming and this is the first time me coming to the server.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, welcome in.
Hello.
I was just admiring the art on your house over here.
Oh, my God.
What the heck?
That's my house, by the way.
You see the purple house over there?
That's not...
That's not Michi's house.
No.
Yeah.
It's not.
It was my house.
It was my house and people putting on paintings on it and now it's...
People cannot see the magnificent house that I built.
Yeah, who would do that?
Who would put a painting on your house?
It's so messed up.
Yeah.
Wasn't it you?
I don't know what you're talking...
See, those aren't mine.
Those...
I didn't do those.
Would you like to see the house?
Yeah.
Give me one second because I have to change my keys.
Of course.
Sprint...
Sneak...
Oh.
Oh...
Okay.
Okay, I'm good.
I'm good.
Oh, welcome.
This is my house, my beautiful house.
It's covered now, but it's my beautiful house.
Whoa.
Oh.
It's...
It's really...
Beautiful?
Mm-hmm.
What...
Why you're...
Why you're like that?
You're not something...
I was impressed.
Who is that?
Okay, that's...
That's...
Mochi.
And...
Maybe.
That's Katie.
Is that...
Is that Mochi?
Also, Mochi built a house for me.
Would you like to take a look inside?
Yeah!
It's right here.
Oh.
Enjoy.
What's that sound?
Right here?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's inside here.
It's inside here.
In here.
Okay.
Oh, I won't die.
I don't know what place is this.
I don't know what place is this, but...
It's something.
What is that sound?
You have like a wild animal in here.
You good?
Okay, let me take you back to there.
Oh my God.
You can grab people.
You can...
She's grab...
Oh my God, she's got me.
A leash.
Oh my God.
You press shift and then right click and you can hold people.
But it has to be empty hand.
Shift right click.
It's not working.
Oh really?
Do you have anything on your hand?
No.
Oh, she meant sneak.
Oh.
Oh, my sneak's not working though.
I don't know why.
Oh.
Let me try this.
Oh yeah.
It has to be sneak and touch.
Like that.
Why is my sneak not working?
Oh.
I think the original key it should be a shift.
Yeah, but I changed it.
It's okay.
Oh, you changed it.
Yeah.
You can try it later.
Wow.
That was so much fun.
Also, we have a things that is closed.
Oh.
We have a way stone.
So, if you touch it, you can keep it here anytime you want.
Oh.
Henya Land.
Yeah.
Make sure you touch it every time when you see this.
I'm gonna always be here.
Henya Land.
Why are you licking it?
Because it's actually delicious.
It's a stone.
Yeah, but it says Henya Land on it.
Yeah.
Of course.
I'm gonna do a summoning circle here.
Oh, Henya.
Henya.
Oh, no.
What did I just get into?
Nothing.
It's all good.
Oh, please don't bother me.
A lot of signs.
Zen faced it.
Ready for a fun...
Oh.
Well, actually, you can't get inside because Ari gave me this magnificent sign.
But we can get in from here, I guess.
Okay.
Oh.
Whoa.
Here it goes.
Ta-da-da-da.
Whoa.
Welcome in.
Oh.
What was that?
Ew.
Oh.
That's my pet.
What's...
That's my pet, Salma.
What is your pet?
My pet is right here.
Right here.
Where?
My friend, Dayo and Jeff.
Oh.
Dayo and Jeff.
Yeah, Dayo and Jeff.
Get inside.
Oh.
Jump.
Skill...
Skill issue, Dayo.
Get good, Dayo.
I'm getting good.
What are they?
Dayo.
Oh.
Mouse is here.
Mousey.
It's okay, Dayo.
Yeah.
Day nine.
When you have a pickaxe and when you get close to them, they're going to get scared because they saw we're going to mine them.
Oh.
Do it.
No.
I don't want to kill...
I can use...
I have nothing to...
Oh.
I have...
This.
Stay back.
Oh, that's for building.
That's for building.
Oh.
Yeah, that's Olympic.
I can give you one of these.
Okay.
And here's my...
There's so many...
So many signs.
I know.
Thanks to Zed.
Oh.
Whoa.
We have a lot of mods in here, so there's a lot of, like, new decorations and stuff.
Yeah.
Everything looks new.
I'm sick of it.
Have you ever played modded Minecraft before?
No.
This is my first time.
Oh.
It was first time for me, too.
But a lot of people will teach you because people are so nice in here, so...
Yeah.
You'll love it.
Wow.
Oh.
Yeah.
And this is my kitchen.
Whoa.
I can't see anything right now because of the sign.
But this is my kitchen.
Oh.
I can't see anything.
Long.
Zed.
I have a panda.
Yeah.
Wow.
Uh-oh.
Henya, I think...
Do you want me to do your dishes for you?
Oh, yeah.
Really?
Thank you.
Yeah.
I'm a maid, you know.
It's been sitting there for, like, six months.
Thank you.
No problem.
I'll clean it with my tongue.
You know?
She's like a maid dragon.
Oh, yeah.
She's fine.
Oh, you're a maid dragon?
Oh, yeah.
I'm a maid ghost.
You know?
Same thing.
Thank you for cleaning.
Maybe I can do it by myself, too.
Thank you.
My mom will take care of it.
Are you sure?
I'll clean the whole kitchen, you know?
No, no.
It's your first time.
You should...
You should enjoy this place a little.
What about we go somewhere else?
Okay.
No worries.
Well, I think Mouse is here.
Oh.
Look.
I think you can get out from here.
The door.
I got it.
I'll fix this one.
Mouse!
Oh my god.
You look like a Gaia Online crazy character.
Hello!
What is this?
Honey!
Here we go.
Oh my gosh.
So cute.
Hi, Mouse!
Yummy!
It's yummy?
It's yummy.
Oh
my god.
I was showing her a lot of places.
I was wondering where should I take her.
You want to see other people's house?
Yeah.
I want to see everything.
Everything, though.
Everything.
How about we go to this house?
Okay.
Oh wait.
Before that, maybe we can go look at the art gallery, too.
Oh.
Yeah.
You're going to have so much fun in here.
Oh my god.
There's so much.
Oh, you finished the art.
Let's see it.
So, this is the art gallery that Mouse built it.
You built it?
Oh my god.
Yeah.
And we put a lot of fan art in here.
There's a sign posted on the art wall.
Oh.
Wow.
I wonder if I can take it.
Oh my god.
Wow.
It looks so cool.
Oh, so cute.
I know.
Every month she's going to put out the new art for the month.
And she keeps taking it every month.
Wow.
Oh my god.
It looks so go- Oh.
It looks so good.
I love this one.
This is the second one.
It looks perfect.
Yeah.
I like it too.
Here we go!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, cute!
A bow in front...
This is where I'm gonna make my house, right here.
In front of this one.
Right here!
Oh my god, this is from Helldivers!
This is from Collab...
This is so cute!
I love it!
I made an honorable...
Honorable entry into the art gallery.
She's going to put a guest picture too, she said.
Oh, cute!
Yeah!
Wasn't it third floor?
Was it third floor, Malice?
For the guest picture?
Or in the first and second too?
Third floor, I'm not finished.
Oh, okay.
I'm excited to see it then.
Oh la la!
Cute!
I love how I can see the people's art in the Minecraft as well.
Like, you can download it and you can like...
You can...
You can see the favorite picture in the Minecraft as well.
Yeah!
That's what I said!
Sexy!
We need a R18 part of the gallery.
Don't apologize Mousey!
It's art.
Yeah, it's art.
There actually will be one!
So cute!
Oh, cute!
This one is like...
really fancy.
It's called Hentai and it's art.
Oh!
Oh, that's cute!
Yoho, yoho!
Pirate life for me!
Oh, I like this one!
I like how Hentai is like experiencing it too.
Yeah, this is my first time seeing it for this month.
Oh!
It's so cute!
Does it take a long time?
Yeah!
A whole day!
There's so much too.
You said there was a second story?
Second floor?
Oh, I see!
Yeah, you can go there!
Three floors.
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
Boing, boing!
Boing, boing everywhere!
You have good taste, mouse.
You have good taste.
Boing, boing, boing, boing, boing!
Sometimes you get that article.
Cute!
Wow, indeed!
Wow, wow, wow!
Oh, I was like, what does she hold?
Oh, those are cuffs.
Oh my gosh!
So pretty!
Oh, this one is so cute!
What if you and Mata floating in there?
Oh my god!
That'd be so cute!
Cool!
Cute!
No, I love this one!
It's so cute!
Oh yeah, this one is so cute too!
Oh, it's for the...
That outfit is from the...
Anime collab one!
That looks so cute!
That's so cute!
Oh, I like the Zen one too.
Aww, this one is cute too!
Cute!
Everything is so cute!
I know!
I love modern Minecraft!
There's so much stuff that you can do!
Oh my god!
It's like they're 3D!
It's like they're gonna jump out of the screen at me!
Hahahaha!
It's so big!
Cute!
You can't go back!
I remember seeing this one on Twitter!
Which one?
The comic of you and Haruka.
She says, Since we're here, let's go out!
And your eyes say no.
No!
Hahahaha!
This one is my favorite too!
No dial!
Never dial!
Simple and easy!
No dial!
Oh, there's a ladder over here too!
Oh!
Here we go!
Oh, there are still...
Oh my god!
Oh, cute!
Wow!
Gengar!
That's my boy right there!
Hahaha!
Gengar!
Me too, Mousy!
Yeah, I love Gengar too!
I'll play a game with only Gengar.
Sometimes.
Really?
Yeah, I'll beat all Pokemon with just Gengar.
Hahaha!
Gengar!
Oh, Gengar!
So yeah, this is an art gallery we have.
It's so beautiful!
Also, down there...
Down there we have a post office too.
Would you like to look at it?
Oh yeah!
Let's go!
Okay.
This way?
This way, this way!
There's so many buildings now.
There's so many buildings.
It's so active in here.
It is!
There's so many people in the server as well.
That's so awesome!
Yeah, it is!
Oh dear.
I'm gonna get lost.
It's so huge!
Here's the...
Here's the post office that we have.
I've also mouse filled this one too.
Oooh, I like these doors!
Fancy...
Fancy!
I think you can use this place to send them...
a gift and letter to people?
Wait, real?
I do have a mailbox.
But once you place the mailbox...
When you put the stuff in here...
They will deliver it to your mailbox automatically.
Yeah, click right here.
Click this one.
I'm gonna start sending creepy letters to everybody.
Yeah, it's so fun.
It's so fun.
It's so cool.
This is so cool.
Oh my god.
There's Herobrine.
I think he works here.
Hey, do your job, Herobrine.
He helps out a lot.
Oh good.
Keep doing your job.
Maybe you'll get a raise one day, Herobrine.
Car.
The garage is so funny.
Yeah, we have a garage, a door, and also...
Oh, this is a portal for Nether.
So if you go in here, you go to the Nether.
Are we going?
We can if you want.
Here we go.
Oh, except me.
Somehow bound to S-Control or something instead.
I'm trying to bind it to just regular control.
Even the Nether is so different too.
Yeah, I was gonna say it's so different.
It's a lot different.
You'll love it.
It's so cool.
We even said that it introduced itself, the Nether.
No, no, no, no.
Look over there.
Blue Forest Palace.
It's so blue.
It's so beautiful.
It is, it is.
Wow.
They have a lot of cool stuff too, so...
I hope you enjoy it.
Oh, the lights!
Wait, who's that?
There's an old man walking around.
Old man?
Yeah, I think so.
The traveling merchant.
Oh, he's just in here?
He's chilling in here.
Wait, he's here?
He's in the Nether?
Oh my.
You're gonna die, mister.
Why the heck he's in here?
You're gonna die in here.
I'll employ Neato Villager.
Neato Villager.
Neato Villager, what are you doing in here?
Yeah, he's actually unemployed.
Why he's in here?
Ah!
Oh, what just happened?
What's that sound?
Oh, that's a hookshot.
Oh, I thought I was gonna... I thought I was about to die.
What was that?
Oh, the village looks really different, too, from the vanilla Minecraft.
It's a lot bigger.
Wait, so there's different biomes and stuff, too?
Would you like to see it?
Yeah!
Okay, oh.
When you...
When you type slash spawn...
You can go back to the spawn area anytime.
Oh, okay.
Slash spawn.
That's it?
Yeah, and... and send.
Oh!
That's crazy!
See?
It's so good.
No, I did not see the pink house.
This is so cursed.
Everybody was talking about it.
The pink house?
Wait!
That looks so cute!
Oh, pink cows!
Okay, hold on.
Mint!
Hello?
Hit you!
It's so good to see you!
I...
Mint!
I'm being led.
I don't know what's going on.
Mint!
Welcome to the server.
I got these for you.
Me?
And I made you spaghet.
Spaghet?
You can make spaghet?
Wait, how do I get it?
Grab this...
Oh!
Who is stealing my spaghet?
Welcome!
Thank you!
It's so exciting that you're here!
Oh my gosh!
I'm gonna eat it.
Oh!
You put it in your mouth!
I... I... I got an achievement.
Wow!
Yummy!
Mamma mia!
Buon appetito!
Oh, thank you!
You're so welcome!
Has she seen the museum?
Yeah, we just did.
She just got here.
So far we saw...
Oh my gosh!
The museum and nether?
The museum is the best part.
Yeah!
You have to see the swamp!
Oh, the swamp?
Oh yeah!
Is this one over here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh, uh, hold on.
I live in the swamp.
You can get out from here.
This way, this way.
Ah, okay.
There we go.
Okay.
Let's go swamp!
Swamp!
Oh my god!
There's new content!
Oh yeah!
Give it to me!
You can feed him fish or honey.
I have honey.
Honey!
Yeah, if you throw a honeycomb at him, he holds it in his hand and he eats it.
It's so cute.
It's cute!
It's so sticky cute.
It's like the pandas.
I think they do that too.
Yeah!
Yeah, they're so cute!
That's true, that's true.
Oh, oh.
Light as a frog.
What did I become?
Oh, touch the waster!
If you're ever missing any resources, you just go into that spooky little temple back there and you can just take whatever's in there.
That one over there?
Yeah.
I made the house and the temple.
Can I go see the temple?
Yeah, whenever you need anything, you can just go inside there and you can just take it.
It's free.
You can just take it.
Am I gonna die?
No, no, no, no.
You're just going to make a deal.
Make a deal?
Oh, that's easy.
Yeah.
In here?
Touch the computer.
There's so much stuff in here!
You should make one too.
You don't need to make a warehouse.
It's all the stuff I've collected.
What the hell?
Oh my god!
There's so much here!
There's a bunch of chests down here.
And when you connect it with these terminals, you just need to put the random stuff in the chest.
Or you can put it in from here.
And they'll do all the organizing and everything by themselves.
So you don't need to do it.
Wait, my crouch isn't working.
Hold on, let me try changing it again.
I don't know why my keybind is acting funny.
Wait, I didn't know you could actually go inside of the storage.
Yeah, you can!
Wait, how?
I want to see how many chests you have.
I want to see how nuts it is.
It's from here, it's here, it's here.
Do you see the, like, a pipeline?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You go down there.
Wait, let me see your chest.
Let me see your chest.
Oh!
There's a ha- Oh!
Oh my gosh!
It's setting to add S, I don't know why.
Froggy!
Huh?
What about pressing C?
Can you do this?
C?
C!
Yeah!
Oh, I can do the C!
Did you change it?
Something just happened!
Oh, I don't know what's going on.
Oh!
Hold on!
Oh no!
I think I messed up!
It's fine, it's fine.
Oh, what's going on?
What's going on?
It's okay, it's okay.
You can do it, you can do it.
You can come over here anytime.
Okay, I'll come right now.
Oh wait, I think I...
Yeah!
I think, wait, I think I... Okay.
What the?
Why is it not working?
Click delete?
Take your time, take your time.
I'm sorry!
It's okay, it's okay.
What's going on?
Now both are bound to C.
No, because I reset it though.
Oh, it doesn't still work?
Sorry, I was yelling at Ari.
Oh, see this is what's bound to open wardrobe.
We'll do... we'll do zero.
No, let me peep that chest.
Yeah, I'm trying to peep that chest.
Peep that chest?
What do you mean peep that chest?
Oh my god!
I
do like, peep.
Holy crap!
What the heck?
I don't know.
Reset, reset.
Oh, wait a minute.
I can DP you, I guess.
Hold on.
Oh, I guess that's true.
What do you mean I'll see something crazy?
What do you have in here?
Hold on.
Let me go inside here.
Let me just clear it.
But I first...
Wait, what's it?
What's it DP?
I don't know why the CNS are here.
Oh, I did!
Wait, so I do...
Oh!
Oh my god.
My computer is chunking.
I'm playing at 2 frames per second right now.
This room is... this room is beefy.
Holy smokes.
What is this thing?
Inventory cable.
Oh my god.
Yeah, when you have this, you just place a random stuff and you don't need to make a warehouse.
I love this.
You just need a big room that's full of chests.
That's all you need.
It's easy to set up too.
You can fix everything.
It's a computer that lets you access your stuff.
What?
That's crazy!
Yeah!
You should have one!
It's easy to make one!
Oh my... modded Minecraft is amazing.
It is!
Oh, there's a waystone over here.
You can put your stuff in the inventory.
Oh, there's a waystone in here even?
Yeah!
Right here!
Satan's services.
Pressing the button while pressing delete.
Okay, let me try.
No!
Mint keybinds are spugged and might be have to reset the config file?
Wait, really?
Yeah, they're kind of weird.
Is it that bad?
Yeah, it's a little weird, but only for sneak.
I don't know why.
Wow!
You got a gift from Mousa!
Oh!
I got diamonds!
Yeah!
Oh, that's a lot of diamonds!
Thank you, Mousa!
Thank you!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna hold on to them.
Yeah!
Wait, what's this?
Oh, bouquet!
Oh, give me this!
Oh, Froggy gave you that!
They're my color!
Oh my gosh, you're right!
Mousa!
Welcome!
Where am I?
You have three minutes to escape before your command.
Your computer explodes.
What will you do?
No, no, no, no!
It's so laggy.
Stop!
You're making the lag worse.
You're really making it worse...
You're gonna explode your PC if you keep doing that!
Oh, okay!
So, slash-spawn?
Yeah, slash-spawn.
Okay!
Oh...
There you go!
My house is next to...
Yeah, let's go set it on fire!
Lucky Fox Casino!
We have casino!
Why are you crying?
Look at it!
I got zero dollars!
I'm broke!
I lost my money.
It's a skill issue.
Well, let's see if you have a good luck.
Okay.
One item at a time.
Send here and wait.
Thank you!
What do I wait for?
So you put the item, something valuable inside there and you spend right there.
Okay, I'll throw a diamond.
And wait for it.
You got something!
Look at it!
What is this?
Yay!
I got a gold block!
Oh my god!
Nice!
How do I get out?
Oh yeah, yeah.
Did I did it?
Did it work?
Oh, I hear something.
Yeah, I think so.
Oh yeah!
I got it!
Where
did she go?
Where did she go?
I'm up here!
Oh, hi!
Hi!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
I think... What happened there?
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
Yeah, I noticed we don't lose anything.
It's so awesome.
Yay!
No penalty.
Yup.
Yeah, when you die, you're not gonna lost your stuff like in the Vanilla Minecraft.
Yeah, it's so nice.
You keep your item.
We used to have a gravestone, but we had too many gravestones and that caused a lag.
So we had to remove it.
Yup.
I get it.
That's okay.
You know?
Who cares about the dead, right?
Yeah!
Who cares about the dead?
And this one is a dead house.
You have to go up from here.
Okay.
Where did she go?
There's a technique to go up.
Don't worry about it, Mossy.
Wait, where is it?
Where did she go?
Up here, up here.
You see that water pool?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
And you go up.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I won't drown.
It's like a... It's Laputa.
Yeah, it's like a Laputa.
Our house is like a Laputa.
She has a little aquarium over here.
There's a fish here.
Oh, my God.
Crab rave.
Yeah.
There are so many new mobs in the ocean too, so I hope you enjoy it.
Yeah, it's so awesome.
There's so many... Everything.
There's so much.
Yeah, it is.
Wow.
Sunfish.
We have bosses and everything.
Oh, my gosh.
What?
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I want to be so many bosses.
I have so many bosses to beat.
What's this?
And then, that's a... That's a Zen's house over there.
You see the pink building?
That's a Zen's house.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
This one?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, I thought I was about to die.
Oh, be careful.
There are so many holes in the ground.
Oh, I saw this picture from down there.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Thank you for a big present.
I gave this art to every single one of them house.
And...
Yeah.
What?
So if I build a house, will I get one?
Yeah, of course.
You'll get one too.
Oh, my God.
It will be my honor.
It's Giga-chan's house.
You're already a Giga-chan.
Oh, thank you.
You too.
Oh, I didn't think...
Zendaya clogged her toilet.
Eww.
Wait.
What is this?
Isn't that a...
Oh, that's a...
Is this a person?
Oh.
Ta-ta-ta.
Whoa.
I think he was using the bathroom.
Oh.
He didn't wash his hands.
Nasty.
Eww.
I don't like it.
It's so cute.
Look at the microwave.
What the heck, Zend?
You got the salad in the microwave?
Shaking my head, Zend.
It's Entrea from V-Shojo.
Shaking my head.
I'll just set it.
I'll set it to 500 minutes.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Make it to 1,000.
1 ,000.
1,000 minutes.
Beep.
Oh, it almost fell out.
Are you okay?
Yep, I'm okay.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, welcome back.
What is this?
Oh, it's a cat.
Why does it sound like that?
Yeah, it's a cat.
Oh, that's a limpet.
That's a limpet as well.
When you go up here... Oh, there's more.
I think this is her bedroom, I guess.
There's a... Wait, there's a Herobrine again.
What's a maid here, O'Brien?
Wait a minute, I thought he's at the...
a post office.
He's in tier 2?
Maybe she's renting this to him.
Maybe, maybe.
Airbnb.
Oh, this is a limpet.
This is a limpet.
Oh.
It's...
It's kinda... It's like Gary from Spongebob.
Oh, wait, that's true.
Meow.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Zen.
Do you think these will fit me?
Oh my god, the cinnamon hole!
Oh my god, it's so cute!
Oh my gosh, no way.
Yeah, it looks so cute!
Look.
I'm looking.
Is he like a little buddy?
It's melting cinnamon!
It's so cute!
The card for my birthday!
Oh my god, that's so sweet!
Aww.
Oh my god, that's so cute!
He's my god.
I pray to your god.
It's so adorable.
Oh my gosh.
I like your... I like your Dejiko hat too.
The Dejiko hat looks really cute too.
So it is a Dejiko hat.
I thought it was.
Yeah, it is a Dejiko hat.
I like it a lot.
Me too!
Oh my gosh.
He even has the bells and everything.
Oh, I think she's asking you.
Sorry, sorry.
There we go.
No, it's okay.
If you want to try it on, I'll sniff it after.
No, it's your day!
It's your day!
Oh my god, it's so cute!
Aww, cute!
Oh, I thought it was so cute!
I gotta find mine too.
Dejiko hat is so cute!
Wait, is it just to borrow?
Or have?
If I get another one...
Aww, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Arigato!
Fight to the death?
Hey, fight to the death!
I can... I have a death by burger.
I wish I could take her panties and whack you with them.
Well, you... I'm pretty sure you can make one really, really soon.
It's easy to make one, so if you want panties, you get one.
Can I wear them on my head?
Oh, wait a minute!
I have a perfect one for you!
Hold on.
Now I'm scared.
Can you see the discord?
Uh...
Yeah, yeah, I can see.
I think you'll love it.
Okay.
Everybody can use it.
There you go.
Here, perfect for you.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna put it on right now.
Yeah, do it, do it, do it!
Okay, okay, okay.
Give me one second, everybody.
This is important... this is important... stuff going on.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna lurk your stream.
I'm gonna lurk your stream.
One moment, everybody.
There he is.
There he is, chat.
He's doing it.
That's a perfect fit!
What do you guys think?
Yay!
Perfect!
That's a perfect fit, I think.
I'm gonna lurk too.
Yay!
Matching!
This is my uniform, everybody.
This is...
This is my magical girl uniform.
You look perfect now.
Thank you.
Oh, booty girl!
Wait, that actually suits Enya so much.
Thank you.
Iron Mouse gave you a... she gave you a hat.
Puchiko?
Oh, thank you, Mouse!
Arigato!
Oh, it's a Puchiko from Dejiko Cat!
Yeah!
Isn't it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Thank you, Mouse!
Arigato!
That's so cute!
I like it!
Thank you, thank you!
Kawaii!
Arigato!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, I'll never take it off.
I'll never take it off.
Puchiko!
Arigato, Mouse!
Yay!
Now we're matching.
We are, we are.
Where else is there?
Okay.
Okay, the next one is... I think it's her... her house?
I think this is the last one from this house.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh, she also got a mini-mart as well.
She made like a little market as well.
Oh!
It's this way.
Okay.
Oh, I see it!
Everything's in the sky.
She's building a sky village.
Whoa!
Sky town.
Oh, what kind of snacks do they have here?
They got, they got some cool snacks, they got shopping cart, they got wine, they got apple, radish.
Oh, they have everything.
Apples.
They got everything in here.
And we got the cash register over here.
I'm just gonna steal.
Yeah, steal there.
She's not gonna notice.
Yeah, she's not gonna notice.
Let's take it all.
Let's rob this place.
This place is so tall, I can't see anything.
Me neither.
This place is so tall.
We need a small people market.
Yeah!
Everything is so tall now.
But that means...
The...
Maybe we get bigger size and so...
It lasts longer for us.
Because we're so small.
This is the best one.
Hmm.
So that's a big house and...
I'm okay.
Obviously.
No problem.
No problemo.
No.
We should make her a mermaid.
Yeah, we should.
How do I make it again?
Mermaid.
She can make it.
Oh my god.
She's a genius.
Oh, so are you.
Maybe...
Mouse is more of a genius.
Wait, what do you mean?
I am the genius though.
Yeah, but she's making it.
She made the mermaid.
Thank you.
I just wear this?
And then I become a mermaid?
There you go.
You're a mermaid now.
Oh, I am.
Oh my god.
Oh, look at my tail.
Yeah, look at you.
You can change your color too.
Yeah, you'll never drown.
And you're so fast, Mouse.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
You guys, I'm a mermaid.
I wanna be where the people are.
Under the sea.
Thank you, Mousey.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you, Mousey.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Wow.
Modern Minecraft does everything.
And this one right here is Melody's house.
Oh, oh my god.
The cinnamoroll.
Yeah.
Melody built it.
What is this brick?
Wait.
Cyan.
It's a white concrete and white purple box.
Silt.
So cute!
Yeah!
It is, it is!
Oh my god, it's so pretty!
Oh my gosh.
All the houses look so nice.
I love the windows!
F5.
For what?
Now home!
Cute!
What's this?
A silver envelope.
What is this?
Oh cute!
There's a cat.
Oh the cats sleeping are so cute!
Oh my god, wait.
I know!
It's so cute!
I'm inside Mel's bed.
I don't know, this might be kind of dangerous.
It's okay.
She doesn't know, she doesn't know.
We are in.
We are in!
How's the smell?
It smells...
Oh,
also she has a pet as well.
She has a pet as well.
Huh?
Yeah, come to the backyard.
Backyard?
Yeah.
Go in here.
Look!
Oh, in here!
Oh!
Whoa!
Is he gonna eat me?
Bad dragon.
Can I ride?
I think he's not hungry today.
Can I ride on his back?
Yeah, you can try.
Come on.
Out!
Come here.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Whoa.
What's happening?
Ow!
Oh!
He's scared.
He's a bad dragon.
Yeah, he's bad.
You're mean.
Bad dragon.
I wanna make a hat out of him.
This is Melody's place.
I will kill him.
It's okay.
I can probably...
I don't want to hit him either just in case.
I don't know what his health is like.
He's so cool though.
I wanna...
I want him.
Maybe I can push him in back?
Oh!
Okay.
There you go.
So yeah, this is Melody's place.
I think she's building a new one.
Somewhere.
It's so cute.
Oh my god.
The trees even.
Wow.
Oh yeah, it's here, isn't it?
Magnolia.
It's so pretty.
A lot of pretty trees.
Yeah.
We have so many trees and it's so pretty.
So that's Melody's place.
Cool.
And the next one...
Here we go.
So the next one...
Oh, this is Camilla's house.
As well.
With my amazing art that I have.
Yes.
And the next one...
Oh.
We're in the prayer room.
This is Camilla's place.
Oh.
Wow.
He had an open door field.
But he stole my watermelon.
So Mouse and I and Addy decided to cover his entire place with a watermelon.
Oh.
I think it looks so much better like this.
Yeah, I like it too.
Yeah.
Like the art of him getting attacked.
He's building a train for the server.
And Giga-chan, HENYA.
Yeah, Giga-chan.
HENYA.
Exactly.
Yeah, Giga-chan.
HENYA.
Exactly.
Oh my gosh.
If I steal from HENYA, what will you create?
Oh, you'll see.
You'll see it though.
Oh, wow.
Oh, he really likes these spinning things.
Yeah, there are so many things in here.
Yeah.
Wait, he made a train.
I want to get on.
Wait, it's actually...
He's making a train.
It's a train run.
Oh my gosh.
It's a hell run again.
What the heck?
Oh, wow.
It's so fast.
It is.
Why are there so many Endermen here?
Oh, I hear a spider too.
Is this dangerous?
Wait.
That's so cool.
He's making a train.
One shot kill.
I will protect.
Okay, Mousey.
I leave it to you.
Oh, am I...
Oh.
Are you...
Are you okay?
No, don't get hit by train.
How do we get on the train though?
It's so fast.
It is.
I tried it but I couldn't.
Okay, I'm going to run at it.
What the heck?
So close.
But yeah, he has a lot of stuff over here.
Saving the Herobrine here.
I think you can use it.
Over here?
He has a lot of cool stuff.
I don't really know how to use it.
Because...
I don't know about freedom mod, but he got a lot of cool things over here.
Yeah.
Live, laugh, love.
Oh my gosh.
It's really working in there.
What was that?
I feel like I'm playing a new game.
Yeah, this is completely different.
I think you'll love it.
Because this is so cool.
Yeah.
It's a lot of cool things over here.
Oh, that's why.
What is this?
I don't know.
The water.
So it's okay if you go in.
What the heck?
What just happened?
I was trying to push you in and then I thought something exploded.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, that's her hammer.
Oh.
Wanna try it?
The hammer?
Wow.
No.
What do you mean no?
You killed me.
Oh, there we go.
Hello.
Welcome back.
You bonked me to death.
Strong super bonker.
Super bonker.
Kiss my feet.
Thank you.
Wow.
What else is there?
No, it's okay.
Is this jail right here?
I don't know what this is.
Is it jail?
I'm going in.
It's a jail.
Gonna make a huge prison?
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
We should put Zen in there.
Yeah.
And Matara.
Also, there's a lot of cool houses over there.
Wanna see it?
Yeah.
I wanna see everything.
Here we go.
This way.
Whoa.
So, that's the place we just went.
Oh, wow.
There's even a smiley up top.
Savannah.
Giraffes.
Look.
This is Addy's house.
Whoa.
There's a giraffe.
There's an elephant.
There's a lot of mumps in here.
There are.
They are.
It's so cute.
I know, right?
He's dying, too.
Yeah.
What happened?
What happened to you, giraffe?
I love this tree.
I like this one, too.
What did you call it?
.
Hi.
Hello.
I like your tree.
Yeah.
I have them here for your materials.
It's not gonna, like, stay looking like this.
But I thought it would also be pretty to, like, grow some of these.
And then get rid of the leaves and swap them out with some of these blue and purple ones.
Oh.
Yeah.
Wait.
This one is, like, blue color, too, for the leaves.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm using it for mater- Mouse.
Mouse.
Mouse!
Why?
Oh.
What did I do?
Oh, there's a thing.
I've done nothing wrong.
That's so cute.
Thank you.
I'm intruding.
I don't have any furniture in it just yet.
Because I'm working on a basement right now.
Oh, a basement.
Yeah.
This is here.
Excuse me.
Where'd you go?
I'm inside.
Oh, you're inside?
Oh, you're inside.
Hello.
Sorry.
Do it for her.
The shrine.
You gotta do it for Mouse.
I own Ari's soul.
It's true.
I need this one for Athenia.
Oh, yeah.
That would be really cute.
Really?
I'm gonna make yours, too.
Then I can put it on my house.
Really?
Yeah!
We can do it together.
Oh, my God.
Yeah,
I don't have any furniture in here just yet.
You're a husky.
You're so cute.
Yeah, it's Peanut.
Peanut.
I love it.
Wait, how do you chase a dog again?
So, I put the name tag.
I named it Husky.
And then I put it on the dog and it changed the name.
That is so cute.
Husky.
You're so cute.
And here's a problem.
Your problem is dying.
What's wrong?
Listen, I would appreciate my problems going away.
Your problem has nine lives.
Would you like my problem, Athenia?
But, but, but...
It's your cat.
Yeah, that's my problem.
Poor problem.
You're not a problem.
Poor problem took me an hour to catch.
He's facing the wall.
He's in timeout.
Yeah, he's in timeout.
Yeah, but I've been working on this basement down here.
Can we see it?
Yeah.
I don't have the hallway for it done just yet.
So, it's kind of ominous.
It's just this.
It's a little scary getting down to it.
But the down here looks really, really pretty.
Oh, wait a minute.
I love this fish tank.
It looks so cool.
I haven't finished decorating this just yet.
What?
That's so awesome.
And then I'm underwater down here.
Yeah!
I'm gonna put a bunch of fun fish out there when I'm done.
Oh my, I love it.
That's such a good idea.
It looks so good.
What is that?
Oh, it's one of those pretty glowfish out there.
It's so cute.
It sings.
Yeah, they whistle.
It's so pretty.
Oh my god, it's so cute.
I'm gonna put a bunch of really cool fish out there.
And then axolotl in here.
Because axolotl eat other fish.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, I'm gonna decorate this tank and make it really pretty.
And then keep only axolotl in here.
There are so many axolotls in here.
It's not only like four colors.
They have so many designs.
Oh, really?
What if I break...
But why would you?
Uh-oh.
Why would you break it?
She's a tiny menace.
Why would you do that?
Just kidding.
I won't do it.
Give in to your inner demons.
Your demons.
Embrace it.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I got a good distraction.
Hold on.
Let me put this up.
Touch the doorbell.
There you go.
Does this appease you?
Oh!
Does this appease you, Mal?
Oh, no!
She stole it.
Froggy!
Why are you at my door?
Let yourself in.
Can I come in?
Yeah.
My doorbell's a little violent.
Oh, my God.
It's so cute.
Oh!
It's like sitting on the ground.
Oh, that's adorable.
It's so cute.
It deserves to be here.
I love it.
It looks like it's actually here.
It does.
Who added the soup?
Oh, my God.
That's so cute.
It is cute.
Look at how short they all are.
I found a music disc.
Does anybody need this?
Are you wearing a Sonic hat?
Yeah!
It makes me sparkle!
It's so sticky cute!
That's why you're sparkling.
That's so cool.
It's so cute.
Yeah, Moush gave it to me.
Wait, you're wearing a Pikmin hat.
I just realized that you've been wearing a Pikmin hat this whole time.
No, it's a Puchiko.
Puchiko from...
What?
But it's got the flower around the head.
Look, Pikmi has like a long tail.
Oh, my God!
I thought it was...
What do I do with it?
Oh, you're right!
You're right!
I thought it was the yellow Pikmin.
Oh, he's hot!
Also, how do you have Cinnamoroll like flying around you now?
Yo, what?
How did you do that?
Where did all these Cinnamorolls come from?
Wait, I'm...
Oh, my God, I'm snowing!
Oh!
Oh, cute!
Oh, wait, that's adorable!
You've got a little snowman on your head!
Snow high, Sean!
That's so cute!
That is so cute!
There's snowflakes around you.
That is so, so cute.
That's cute!
Oh, my gosh, you have so much stuff.
How do you get the hats?
You have to find them, I think.
Yeah, you have to find them.
And there's a lot of places that you can go.
There's a cave.
And there's a treasure chest inside there.
So you can get it from there.
Excuse me!
Okay.
I'll ask.
I'll come to you.
I'll make a pact.
I'll sell my soul.
I only have...
I am a soul.
I wouldn't say that, Min.
Only one favor...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll make a deal.
Wonderful.
Yeah.
It's okay.
I'm already dead.
Can't say no.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Years from now.
No worries.
Yeah, yeah.
What could go wrong?
Nothing.
I trust... yeah.
4k favor.
Yeah, that's not an exaggeration.
It's true!
I have quite the debt.
4k?
Oh my my.
You owe a lot, Ari.
Yeah, the amount of gold blocks that I asked for is a lot.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
You owe a lot.
Yeah, she made my beacon for me.
I didn't even make it.
She made it herself.
The block underneath it too, right?
Yeah.
Mouse made it, right?
She did all of that.
Yeah.
Yeah, she got the nether star and everything.
She killed the wither for me.
Yeah.
Mouse kinda owns me.
I remember...
I spawned the wither thinking that I could kill it.
And then I started killing these so Mouse had to come save me and kill it for me.
Wait, how do you sit down again?
Oh, you look at the ground and you double tap shift.
Brains.
So beautiful.
I ain't got one.
I need one.
I don't
know how she did it.
She was like spamming sit, so I guess she just...
Oh my god, Enya.
I give you this.
Rest in peace.
Oh wait, how do I throw it?
How do I throw things?
Hello.
You're giving away the flower bouquet I got you!
No, it was for...
It was for her grave.
I took those flowers and you keep them.
You keep them.
You hear me?
I'm sorry, Froggy.
You idiot.
How do you sit?
You look at the ground and you double tap shift.
Oh.
Oh wait, my thing doesn't...
Oh, my thing doesn't work.
That's right.
My crouch is broken.
You end up going to the ground like Enya.
Wait, why did I go up to the ground?
I think you just spam sit so much you just face through the ground.
What?
What happened?
You can get like some wool blocks and put them down as little bean bags.
Oh.
What's going on?
You got it.
Something's happening to me.
She's freaking gone.
What's going on?
I can't move.
Why are you going in reverse?
I can't go anywhere else.
I can't.
I'm stuck.
I can't go anywhere else to go.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I'm normal again.
Thank you.
I'm learning their motor controls.
I am.
Yeah!
I finally fixed my storage.
I think.
If I remember.
I wanna see it.
It's either really hideous in the basement or I fixed it.
And I can't remember.
I can't remember.
Great.
Uh-uh.
Not if I didn't fix it.
Just like Pete.
No.
If I didn't fix it.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
It's good as Pete looks.
What's that sound?
What's sniffing so much?
It's the bear in my house.
It's Akko riding.
Oh, yeah.
Did you show them Akko riding?
What?
He's been wandering the house.
I don't know who let him in.
Oh, I found him when he's almost dead.
Oh, no.
No.
Oh, there he is.
What is this?
According to all known laws of aviation.
No, it's not according.
It's Akko riding.
Don't make fun of me.
Oh, you met him.
He's so cute.
Yeah, you won't see him.
You won't see him.
Thank you.
Just throw one at him.
Throw it?
Okay.
Yeah, you just throw it at him.
Yeah, when he's done eating that one, he'll pick it up.
Slurp it down.
Oh, my God.
He's so cute.
Oh, father.
So cute.
I love you.
Honey.
How do you heal him?
I think I need to throw a splash potion of healing on him.
Oh.
He's sniffing.
Oh, yeah.
Because Froggy is holding one.
Yeah.
His nose is so bouncy.
Boing.
Yeah.
He's so cute.
I love the little head.
He's so good.
He's so cute.
Wait.
Have you ever seen Meatball?
No.
What's that?
Meatball.
What?
Oh, yeah.
A meatball.
Meatball.
Where is he?
He's over here.
Meatball.
It's Demonic Wizard Meatball.
Oh, right.
Demonic Wizard Meatball.
Oh.
Yeah.
Wow.
He's named after Heavenly.
Oh.
I love how he looks directly at the camera.
I love it.
I know.
If you press Z to zoom in on him, he'll just stare at you really weird.
It's funny.
Wait.
You can zoom?
Yeah.
Hold Z.
I'm zooming in on my map.
I think my keybinds are all weird.
Look at you.
Wait.
He's staring at you.
Hold on.
I want to see if he'll look at me.
He's got an attitude problem today.
Meatball.
Oh, my God.
He listened.
He's so good.
You're a good listener, Meatball.
He really likes you.
Oh, my God.
His eyes.
Yeah.
He's looking at you.
I love him so much.
He's so silly.
He's so cute.
Froggy's place is this way.
This way.
It's the giant mushroom.
Oh, I see it.
I was waiting till you came back around.
I expanded this corner of the grass a little bit.
It didn't really disturb your bridge.
I just had to relocate some lily pads.
I don't mind if you touch my lily pads.
Oh, cute.
Fireflies.
There's even fireflies.
Oh, my God.
I have a bunch of them if you want them.
I actually made a ton.
I actually made too many.
I have a lot of them.
You're a breeder.
You bred the fireflies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can go up here.
Okay.
I'm coming.
Oh, so cute.
Thank you.
You can sit.
Oh, Robin.
Oh, I'm sitting.
We gotta show Buh.
Let me see if I can even find Buh.
I don't know where Buh is.
I hope he's okay.
There it is.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
He's in the plant.
Let me try and get him.
I'm stuck.
Oh, no.
Where are you?
The worm is in here, too.
They're both in here.
Thank you.
What the heck?
Where are you guys at?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
This way.
Oh, this one.
Thank you.
I can't get him out of the plant.
I can't pick him up.
This is Froggy's place.
Smells like frog.
I tried so hard.
I can't get him.
I give up.
Frog.
Frog smell.
Froggy.
I picked the plant up.
You can get him out.
I was thinking of picking up the box.
What a crazy setup.
Is this dynamite?
No.
Nuh-uh.
Don't.
There are no explosives in this house.
Never mind.
I saw nothing.
I'm no fat.
I'm no snitch.
You got a cake?
Yeah.
So cute.
Coffee.
What the hell was that?
I can't pick him up anymore.
Did he get bigger?
Oh my god.
There's stuff in the fridge.
There's raw pasta.
Oh, my cup.
I knew that.
You can actually do cooking in this game.
You can?
Yeah.
You need a bunch of different kinds of pots to cook.
So I've got like a ton of different pots.
Small cooking.
What?
That's crazy.
It's really cute.
Yeah.
And then my unfinished basement is down there.
And then my room is up here.
You have a little man in here.
What?
Steve.
Wait.
What?
There's a tiny man in my house?
Yeah.
He's in your basement.
What?
He's looking at your chest.
Yeah.
What?
Huh?
Yeah.
I think he's stealing your stuff.
Oh, my.
Oh, my heart.
Oh, my gosh.
That's so human.
What did you think of him?
I don't know.
I got scared.
This is the unfinished basement.
Where does this go?
Oh, good.
He goes to prison.
Can I go?
Yep.
And you just ran in.
No hesitation.
And you said I'm in.
That's prison.
And you sprinted.
Wait.
Why would I let you in?
I don't know.
Maybe I'm too...
I think I'm too...
I'm too...
Justice.
I'm not a criminal.
Okay.
Mint.
The problem is that the actual teleport thing is one block up.
Since you're one block tall, you need to jump into it.
Okay.
Prison.
Yeah.
Now we're in prison.
Prison.
What have you done?
They're so cute.
I'm gonna shit.
Prison.
You beat prison.
Jail.
One for everybody.
So you can take everything inside.
How do I say anything?
Yeah, like that.
So don't break these because everyone has their own room.
Yeah.
So you see stuff in there, you can take all of it.
Because that's only generated for you.
And I see something different in there.
Oh, that's crazy.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
They're shared chests.
Everything is shared.
What?
Oh my god, a diamond.
Yeah.
Good.
What's the axe you have?
My thunderbrand?
Thunderbrand.
Yeah, I got it from the prison one time.
Oh.
It's so fun.
This is so cool.
It is.
Book.
I need everything.
I'm broke.
This place is so huge.
Bad ass.
All I've gotten are lame little assassin daggers from the dungeons.
That sucks, dude.
You got thunderbrand?
Yeah, I got thunderbrand.
Oh, I got a weapon.
Did you get a weapon?
Yeah.
Which one did you get?
The gold scythe.
Nice.
Oh.
Watch out.
I'm a new...
What's that thing?
Oh, that's an enemy.
It is?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, there we go.
Oh my god.
The prisons are full of treasure but they're also full of enemies.
You gotta be careful.
This is so fun.
Oh my god.
It's so cool.
You can get a lot of really good things in here.
Don't the prisons reset after a certain amount of time?
I don't know.
I don't know either.
I don't think they do.
No, I think this is like a prison that's...
I think you have to like destroy your portal and redo it to get a different prison.
Oh.
That's smart.
Joel gave me the portal and I was like it's funny if I put it in my basement.
Yeah, I was like how did you get that?
Yeah.
Assassin.
Oh.
Uh oh.
Well.
That's it for Ahri.
We're never seeing her ever again.
She's gone forever.
Ain't nothing you can do about that.
She's gone.
Oh, hi Ahri.
Welcome back.
You made it.
I think there's a guy right behind me.
Oh.
Um.
Uh oh.
I'm gonna skill issue you.
Don't do it with Thunderbrand.
It's so cool.
I think there's like a lot of really cool things here.
This kind of portal is everywhere you see it at the outfield.
Uh.
So when you find it, you can go inside and get the loot.
Ah.
There's so many portals out there.
So they're all random?
Yeah.
I will say there's like a boss in each prison.
I wouldn't attack the boss.
Because when you attack it, it closes it off for everybody else.
Oh.
Okay.
You actually can't go in the prison anymore once the boss is eaten.
I've never seen a boss before.
How do you see him?
The prison I used to go to, I think Heavenly defeated the boss there.
And now I can't go in there anymore.
Oh.
Oopsie.
Really?
Yeah.
It's closed off.
Oh no.
Okay.
Yeah.
Why would you do that to me, Heavenly?
Oh wait.
Maybe this one.
Okay.
Zen raided me and I didn't notice for hours.
Oh no.
I'm so sorry, Zen.
The tea is ready.
Thank you, Zen.
I was so focused on the game.
Thank you for playing.
I hope you had a wonderful time.
Finally.
Yes.
I am so sorry.
Finally.
I even forgot I was streaming.
Sorry.
Thank you, Zen.
Arigato.
Oh my goodness.
Hello, Raiders.
Welcome.
We're playing Minecraft with Mint, Addy, Froggy and Hanya and everybody.
This is the first time Mint joining the server.
It's the first time.
I hope you've enjoyed.
Yeah.
First time.
My first time.
Oh my gosh.
This is so exciting.
Everything's new.
Look at this guy.
Can I take him home?
Oh, you can.
You can destroy him with a pickaxe.
I think it has to be a...
Is she talking about a corpse?
Maybe.
Can I take this home?
You can.
You can take him home.
Hold on.
There you go.
Oh my god.
I have him.
This is one of the first things you want on the server.
A corpse.
A tiny little skeleton.
Spooky scary skeleton.
Slippers for spying.
I like stealing these torches a lot at the time too.
They're really neat.
I like them.
Yeah, they're good torches.
Yeah.
Wow.
I want to keep just exploring all the... but this place is dangerous, right?
It is.
But if you're with somebody that has a good weapon, it's not too bad.
Yeah.
But if you're with somebody that has a good weapon, it's not scary anymore.
I saw an area where you can go down.
You can go under the prison.
And I haven't been able to find it again.
Like, I found it just once.
This hole that goes under the prison and I haven't been able to find it.
Oh, that was a different prison.
No, I swear it was this one.
I swear it was this one.
I'm not lying.
It's your first time here.
What do you mean?
How can I be lying?
What are you saying?
I've got a big sword.
Oh, wow.
Look at you.
You've got a big sword.
Look at it.
I swear there was a little hole where you could drop down.
And there was more to the dungeon.
I swear to God.
The audio crunches that?
How do I get the regular backpack?
Thank you, guys.
Hold on.
I have a gift for you.
A gift?
Uh-huh.
If you give me a little bit of money.
Okay.
I thought you were going to say, give me a little bit of money.
I'll pay you.
Where's your money?
Here, here, here.
I have a gold doubloon.
No, no, no.
It's yours.
Don't give it to me.
No, it's okay.
I'm paying you.
No, no.
It's your first day.
I'm going to give you a backpack that you will love.
Okay.
Will I look so stylish?
Yeah, you will.
You will.
And a leather...
A leather...
What else do I need?
That first day is free.
Oh.
For today.
For today, it's free.
Yes.
How do I get a sleeping bag?
How do I get a sleeping bag, chat?
Sleeping bag...
Oh, okay.
Free wool.
A land cell?
It's not a land cell.
I mean, it's kind of, but...
It's a backpack.
Look.
Look, look.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a backpack.
Wait, did you give it to me?
No, not yet.
I'm making one.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Here's your backpack.
Oh.
Are you going to give it to me?
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Wait, so how do I put it on?
Oh, to hold the backpack, you click it.
And you should be able to see that there's an icon that says like...
Press control.
Oh!
Wait, how do I wear it?
Do you see an icon?
Oh, I have to hold it in my hand?
Yeah, you have to hold it in your hand.
And when you click it, you see the icon.
Steve standing.
There you go.
And we can upgrade it so you can have more stuff inside.
I can upgrade it for you later.
Okay.
Wait.
Yeah!
How do I open it now?
Where does it go?
You press B and then you open it.
B.
O.
V.
B.
And B.
I think my...
Beautiful B.
I think it's my...
I think my keybinds are weird.
I'll do it later.
It's okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, it's still weird?
Yeah, it's okay though.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, but it's so good.
It's so good.
I want to find more treasure.
Let's go find more treasure.
Treasure.
Oh, have you go up here?
Where?
Up here.
You see this chain?
Oh!
Uh-oh.
What's up?
I thought I saw something.
No, no.
What's my achievement?
I collected loot.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Take it all.
Guts.
I like when they drop their body parts.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cool.
Oh, my health.
You're right.
My health?
My health is bad.
Oh, your health?
Oh, do you need food?
Oh, I can't eat honeycomb.
Can I eat guts?
You can.
I'm eating them.
Yummy.
Yummy guts.
Guts are delicious.
Meat, meat.
Maybe.
Oh, there they are.
Hello.
Hi, I'm eating really fast.
Ah!
Killed
by a leaping zombie.
Zombie.
Um...
What's in here?
Nothing.
Why is it open like that?
So many of these things.
Oh, music.
Oh, except.
I'm back.
Welcome back.
I'm tired about that.
It's okay.
It happens, you know.
It happens, it happens.
Yeah, no problem.
Thank you.
Oopsie.
Oopsie-daisy.
Yeah, oopsie-poopsie.
No problem.
Oopsie-poopsie.
More loot.
I like how the enemies didn't spawn until you guys came back over.
They were just chilling, eating food, and then you came over and they just all spawned.
We're just that popular, you know.
They're...
They're like, genius.
Gotta...
My Kamiyoshi.
And you're the genius.
Oh, uh-oh.
Don't know me.
Nice.
Ooh, another treasure chest over here.
Ooh.
Ooh, diamond.
Yeah, you get like diamonds and a lot of stuff.
Running out of space.
Nice.
Oh, you wanna go back?
You gotta make your chest...
What the?
Is that behind me?
Oh my god!
I saved you.
You saved my life.
Savior-dayo.
What's that?
Uh-oh.
She's got this.
I'm just gonna keep taking stuff.
She's built different.
She is built different.
I'm just taking everything.
Welcome to the genius-dayo.
Oh, let's go to the second floor.
Be careful!
It's okay, I got it!
Yeah!
Thank you!
Nice!
This floor goes to deeper.
Deeper.
There's more floors.
I like the tapestry.
Oh, Froggy wasn't lying.
There is!
She doesn't need to know that.
I told you I wasn't lying!
No!
I told you!
Oh, she's here!
Yeah!
I haven't explored yet.
But it keeps going.
Oh!
No!
Froggy, no!
That was impressive.
That was fast.
That was pretty quick.
I don't think Froggy suffered, you know?
It's good.
She died.
It's a quick death.
Also, I can make you a hookshot.
Hold on.
It's really handy when you don't have Elytra.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know about giving you Elytra.
If you want, I can give it to you.
But also, I don't want to take away your experience too.
So, let me know if you want.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
I'll get one myself.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, thank you though.
Of course!
Ari?
Sorry!
Too bad!
No, no, no!
Hanya!
Swing on Mint!
Here you go.
Get her!
Get her, Hanya!
Sacrifice me!
Wait,
hold on.
I'm gonna make you a hookshot.
Hold on.
Okay.
I'm trying to change my keyboard still.
You know, maybe I deserve that.
I'm defeated.
Back at the door.
Yeah.
Don't you give me that, Sassy!
What is it, Ari?
Wait.
You're too sassy.
You're too sassy, Hanya.
There we go.
I'm trying to give her the hookshot.
Oh!
There we go.
Did you see that?
I'm built different.
Are you good?
I think I'm doing Gangnam Style right now.
Hey, sexy lady!
Gangnam Style!
I did a flip even.
Oh, my God.
Get it, man.
Get it.
Welcome back, Froggy.
Watch this.
Thank you.
Hell yeah, brother.
Hell yeah.
I'm learning.
I'm learning every day.
Oh, you found an email.
Yeah.
That was my favorite thing.
Flip!
Oh, my God.
The flip is so funny.
I'll give you a hookshot.
Wait.
I think I need more space.
Uh -oh.
Escape.
Maybe E?
That would be E.
I did it.
Nice!
Yay!
You can go up like this.
It's like a hookshot.
Okay.
There's so much space down here.
Where is it?
Oh, here it is.
Hey, Froggy.
Wait, Froggy.
You have an Electro.
Why did you not just glide down?
I forgot.
Like this?
That's understandable, I guess.
I'm ordering food, okay?
Oh!
I did it.
I just finished eating.
Ah!
Yeah, just like that.
Okay.
Easy peasy.
Thank you.
Of course, of course.
You're cute.
Do you wanna...
Do you wanna put down some of your stuff?
Because you tell me that you're full or not.
Oh, I have a backpack now.
I'm okay.
Okay, okay.
Ow.
Sorry, I have to pee.
Don't let me die.
Okay.
Okay, I have to pee.
Okay, go pee.
I'm...
Please.
Kill her!
Yeah!
Take her down.
Oh no!
She's suffocating!
You didn't kill her.
She suffocated.
Yeah.
Tragedy Dale.
Tragedy Dale!
How'd that happen?
That's so weird.
I think it bugged.
Yeah, it bugged.
It bugged.
It's a weird glitch.
She's gonna see that she suffocated.
That's not possible.
Yeah, you didn't kill her.
Yeah.
Okay, there we go.
I think it's dead.
No!
Adi died!
You're so strong, Hannah.
Thank you.
You got a really good armor.
Yeah.
If it wasn't the consequences of my own actions.
My hands were glitched so I couldn't switch to my weapon.
Uh oh.
But I'm good now.
I can take him down.
Get him!
Yeah, I was gonna die.
There was a lot there.
I got a booger.
Experience nugget!
I thought it was a booger.
It was an experience nugget.
What is that?
Oh, yeah.
You cloud and...
You can use it.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
Here.
I don't know if this is better than what you have.
But that's a really good sword.
What is this?
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
It's a blade.
Oh, you look cool.
I do.
She studied the blade.
You look like a Raiden Raiden.
Raiden?
Raiden, Raiden.
Yeah, I'm Raiden.
Yeah.
More stuff for us.
I'm looting everything.
Me too.
It's all mine.
Time to let her rip.
And...
I did.
She keeps having to teleport me.
One day.
Hi!
You did try.
I killed him.
I just also died at the same time.
You know, it's a little...
Necessary sacrifice.
Counterproductive, maybe, a little bit.
I got it.
Pink.
Not that.
What is that?
Sorry, I actually charged up.
Oh, it's me.
My...
My Thunderbrand.
It does like this thing.
Whoa!
Sorry, I didn't mean to hit you.
It's okay.
That's crazy.
Yeah, I can like charge more and hurt people.
You're zooming.
That's cool.
Anything in here?
Nope.
No treasure.
Sometimes it goes further down.
But I'm not sure about this.
Oh!
Nice kill!
Oh my gosh!
She's so cute, the little body.
I'm gonna take him home.
Oh, you want him?
Yeah, I want this guy.
Is it okay?
Yeah, of course.
Thank you!
Zen!
Zen is on!
Hi, Zen!
Oh!
She immediately died.
Help!
It's you!
Zen!
Why is my chat telling me to run?
Uh oh.
She got on, died, and left.
Sorry.
Never mind.
I guess we're safe, everybody.
Good job, Zen.
Alright.
I'm gonna go this way.
I'm following you guys, because I'm weak.
Nice kill!
I'm about to die.
No!
Nice, nice!
Treasure!
I'm getting so many chains.
Yeah, me too.
You can't hit me!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I did it.
There's so many chests.
That sounded close.
Yeah, I have one heart left, so I'm just like...
Do you need some flesh?
Flesh?
I have some guts for you.
You can eat guts?
Yeah!
They're delicious.
You can eat it, you can eat it.
I got a nutcracker.
A nutcracker?
Nice!
I have a food, so I can give you guys if you want to.
What does this do?
Food time!
It deals critical damage to frozen and stunned enemies.
Cool.
Nice, nice!
What's a runic tablet?
I never used it before.
I think it's for fixing weapons?
I think?
Time to break some nuts.
Yay!
Yeah!
Oh, you took it?
Here you go!
Oh, thank you!
Thank you very much.
Yeah!
Not a thing.
I love how every time I get on Minecraft, I do everything but the thing I got on Minecraft to do.
That's how it goes, isn't it?
Oh my gosh, with this, I'm going to be exploring forever though.
Oh, I know the dungeons.
Yeah, I'm going to be going to the dungeons forever.
So many good things.
And all the bodies.
There are like so many things to do in this game.
It's a lot, it's a lot.
Oh no, I broke him!
You broke him?
Oh, maybe it has to be a silk touch.
I think so, it has to be silk touch to take the bodies.
Oh no.
It's okay.
I have silk touch.
I think I only need one stinky man.
Oh, one thing.
Why not two stinky men?
Or three stinky men?
You know what?
You're so right.
Why not have more stinky men?
I made one request to you.
You're failing me even now.
You're letting me die even now.
You're letting me shoot me in the brain.
Oopsie.
I totally forgot.
A lot has happened.
So much happened.
Oh, I see, I see.
Okay, yeah.
You got caught up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whatever you say.
Oh, oh, oh.
I think we're okay.
Oh, oh.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Guys.
Anytime.
You know you can get the claw bar.
Hehe.
It has a cool down.
Just like a half life.
Where did I get this from?
No.
Uh oh.
You're not protecting me.
Am I supposed to?
Yeah.
Oh, you came back so I didn't think that was my job anymore.
Lynn, I found your stinky guy.
You did?
Yeah.
You want him?
A rotten corpse.
Yeah, I'll take him.
Here you go.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Now I have a corpse.
I have a rotten corpse.
I have a skeleton.
I have all three phases.
You got all phases.
Yeah.
Careful.
This is so exciting.
I know.
It's a lot of stuff.
Also, you gotta find a place to build your house too.
Yeah.
You're right.
There are so many places.
Yeah, there aren't so many biomes.
Oh, thanks guys.
Let's see.
The only thing I would suggest is not building near the spawn because it gets a little laggy.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I will not do that.
Mm-hmm.
Mike-chan says, I love we still exploring a froggy's house.
That's true.
We still in the froggy's house.
You're right.
Oh my gosh.
Technically, yeah.
The frog's dungeon.
Yeah.
It's just the biggest house.
It's so much fun.
So many rooms.
She got the biggest house.
I didn't know you had a big basement or prison.
Yeah.
This is where my mods live.
Why does mom let you have a basement?
You're a mod to live in a basement too?
Mine too.
I'm taking care of you.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
I'm okay.
There's like a portal right there.
I can handle myself.
Yeah.
But I couldn't find the boss.
Uh-huh.
Maybe you have to summon him with the item.
Where are
you guys?
How did she die?
I'm behind you.
You're behind me?
Hello.
Chica!
Can you get armor in the chests?
Wait, can we?
I only find a weapon but not armor.
Maybe it's not possible.
Yeah!
That I spawned in Zen's bed.
And Zen was there and I was like, Zen!
And she logged in.
Zen!
She just abandoned me.
I don't know.
Here I go.
Oh!
Oh.
Thank you.
Of course, anytime.
I think it's for the boss.
There's a boss!
I wanna go!
I just hear the distance.
There's a boss?
Yummy!
Yummy guts.
Delicious.
I think I'm becoming a zombie.
Maybe a little bit.
That's a little concerning.
It's okay.
I seek the highest quality of guts.
It's guts.
It's upgraded.
There's a song in Japan.
It's called guts.
Oh, really?
I think it's a very old song.
It takes you to this forest.
Yeah, it takes you to a forest with a bunch of red bees.
There's even a cage.
Yeah.
You should take it.
Oh.
Oopsie.
Oh my gosh.
You guys, I think I'm obsessed.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I think I'm obsessed with the mines.
Not the mines.
The dungeons.
Oh my god.
I will never leave the dungeons.
Ouch.
Wait, what's this over here?
Oh, they're all a bunch of pigs.
That's how I saw it was somebody's birthday.
Uh, Desecrator, happy birthday!
Uh,
Desecrator, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Sorry, it's hard to reach out when, um...
when it's a collab.
But thank you guys, thank you!
Hello!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Nice.
Oh, there's two in here.
More guts.
And iron.
Yeah.
And this... a cobweb.
So many books.
What did you do for that?
Oh, I see what... capacity.
A pentacon.
A who?
What's this?
What's that?
There's so much here.
Wait.
Hold on.
This one's kind of funny.
I just found a weapon.
And it's like this big...
like hammer thing.
And it's called Nutcracker.
That's what I got earlier!
Yeah!
Oh my god, look at him!
Oh no, I kinda wanna take him home.
Well, I can take you...
I can break it for you.
Wait, wait, what was the first one, Hanya?
What?
You can do what?
I can take...
I can take him home?
Yeah!
Oh, thank you!
Of course!
Do the skeletons stack?
Oh my gosh, they do!
I can take home so many skeletons!
You can take home so many.
I'm gonna have a whole room of skeletons.
Also, there's some guts.
He gave you some guts.
More guts to eat.
Eat, eat it.
Oh!
Hey, don't yuck our yum, okay?
Don't... you know...
My bad, my bad.
That's delicious!
Yeah!
You gotta try it!
I'm also eating the guts.
I'm just trying not to think about it.
Don't knock it till you try it.
Wait...
More treasure over here!
Is it this way?
There's more of them!
There's so much treasure!
I know, I know.
This is how you get the good stuff.
Nice!
Oh!
Ouch!
Oh, really?
That's cool!
Whoa!
I guess I just got really lucky.
You found what?
My weapon, Thunderbrand.
It's a really strong weapon.
Thunderbrand!
So it's a gacha.
Oh, what's this?
It's kinda like a gacha every time.
Oh, crowbar!
Yeah, you can be the crowbar.
Just like in their life.
Half-life?
Half-life.
Half-life!
Morgan Freeman!
It wasn't Morgan Freeman?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, watch out!
Morgan Freeman!
Oh, uh-oh.
I died too.
I wonder where I should build my house.
I wonder where I should build it.
Henyon who's Black Mesa now.
Finally.
Morgan Freeman!
I think that taught me really, really well, isn't it?
Hello!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Born to sass people.
Sass dayup.
What's sass?
Are you being sass, Henyon?
No, she's being sassy.
No, I'm being sassy.
Sassy!
Sassy or sassy?
What's the difference?
When you're like skill-ish, you die-o.
And you're mocking me, that's being sassy, Henyon.
No, you die-o.
Geniuses are often sassy, you know.
Let's see...
Is your inventory full?
No, it's okay though.
I got lots of room still.
Nice, nice.
I'm ready to keep collecting.
I think you were almost done in this floor.
I think we went everywhere.
I think so too.
Is there a chest?
No.
Did we go all the way down here?
Oh, I don't know.
Let's go.
Which way?
We went that way.
This way?
We came from this way.
Yeah, so...
And have we gone all the way over here then?
Back here?
Yeah.
Because this part isn't even on the map.
Yeah, you're right.
Well, I haven't gotten this one.
Oh, me neither.
That's why we double checked.
Yeah, I think we have.
I think we have.
Hmm...
We went this way.
This way.
Outer heaven.
Well, I think I've gone this way.
I think this is where I just was.
Apparently this mod is inspired by...
the game is called Dead Cells?
Oh!
It didn't look like that.
Oh, okay.
I got it.
Thank you.
I thought I was a goner.
Yeah, I think we've been everywhere.
Yeah, I think so.
I think so.
Oh, another broadsword.
Hmm...
Oh, gods.
Zelda is universal.
I love Zelda.
Bleh.
Guts.
Oh, I didn't open this one.
More guts.
Guts are a balanced, well balanced breakfast.
Eat your guts, Diana.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, I didn't open this one too.
I think that's it for Froggy's...
Froggy's basement tour.
Yeah, I think so too.
Oh, hi, Mata!
You guys haven't even seen Bob.
Oh, is it Mata here?
Yeah, she's in my chat.
She's calling me a freak.
Oh, hi, Mata!
Yeah, I don't know why.
Why am I a freak?
Mata!
Are you talking about my present from Henya?
It's my very precious presents.
My precious thing.
Yeah, she precious them.
She want to place them in her house.
Mata!
A freak.
I am a freaky ghost man.
Should we go back to spawn and...
see other stuff?
Yeah, I guess so.
Spawn time!
Spawn.
To the spawn.
Oh.
Spawn.
We definitely just abandoned Froggy in there.
Oh, you're right.
She'll be fine.
It's probably okay.
Yeah, she got this.
She'll be fine.
Where else should we go?
Oh, I see the gun run in the sky is gone.
There was a gun run in the sky?
Wait, what?
There was a giant painting of gun run in the sky.
What?
Wait, why did they get rid of it?
I don't know.
I got on the other day and it was just gun run.
There's these ones.
I wanted to see it.
That's so perfect.
They're really cursed.
Those are so cute.
These ones are so cursed.
Oh.
Oh yeah, there's...
These ones.
These beautiful portraits.
Who made it?
It's genius, Tayo.
Those are perfect.
I love those.
I love it too.
The eyes are so scary.
Oh my god.
Rid of the gun run in the sky because it was lagging.
Oh.
Oh, I see it.
The piggies too.
What happened?
Zen is
back again.
Now should I run?
What just happened?
Right click the button.
Oh my god.
Emergency!
Hold on, Zen is up there.
Zen is gone.
What's this?
There's loot here.
Oh yeah?
Where is Zen?
Oh, there she is.
Oh, she left again?
Zen!
You intimidated her.
Where's my genius power?
Do you have any idea that you want to build a house on or something?
I don't know where yet.
I'll find somewhere.
Yeah.
You want to see other people's house?
Okay.
Oh, I want to show you the Amuchi place.
Hold on.
Oh, Amuchi's place is so nice.
Wait.
You're on my head.
Okay.
Why?
Maybe this...
Going on my own...
Hello?
I think...
It's on my head.
Huh?
I'm here.
I don't know how she got up there.
What's going on?
Wait, what do you mean?
You're on my head.
I am?
No, you're on my head.
No, I'm on nobody's head.
You're on my head.
No, you're on my head.
What?
She's on Hanyu's head, but she's also on my head.
I don't see... I see myself on...
Do you see me walking on the ground?
No.
No, I see you on my head.
What?
Let me leave the server and I'll come back.
Okay.
What is going on?
I think the game is bugged.
Did you see my home yet?
It's a hole in the ground.
No, I haven't.
Going on my own...
A tour in Japan in a week.
Any recommendations?
Maid cafe!
Here we go.
What am I wearing?
Oh!
Thank you!
Am I normal again?
Okay.
Oh, the chimes!
They're so cool!
They are!
They make a good sound.
She also made this like a farm for the wool as well.
Oh!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Your crafting methods are so cute!
It is!
I know, right?
Wait, how does it farm?
Um...
I think there's a scissor inside.
And a shear shear inside.
Oh, I see it!
But I think it's not working because the shears are broken.
Oh, it's down here!
It's all working, I think.
Oh, it's this snail thing again.
Scary.
Oh!
Oh, God!
I need to...
Oh, how do I get out?
Oh, there we go.
Mmm!
And this is her room.
Right here.
Whoa!
Oh, my gosh!
She also has dead people!
Oh?
Maybe I should add.
Rod and corpse.
Corpse.
Skele-man.
Corpse, corpse, Skele-man.
I like the skeleton.
I do too.
He's really cute.
Yeah, me too.
I like it.
Also, when you put the corpse on the ground, it makes the mushy sound like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whoa.
Wait, whose house is this?
This is Ruth's.
Oh, okay, okay.
Whoa, there's a piggy head too!
Yeah!
They are.
I knew you were gonna do that.
I'm safe.
I'm safe!
Nice!
Yeah!
I'll go around.
I'll go down.
Here we go.
What is this?
Is there anything down here?
Oh wait, there is some stuff down here.
Oh, wait a minute.
This is...
This is where the treasure at, wasn't it?
Treasure?
More treasure?
Oh, what is that?
I think there is treasure around here.
You good?
Yep, I'm okay.
Oh,
there's the treasure.
There's the treasure.
Zombie.
Whoa, there's a lot of stuff in here.
Whoa!
Wait, is this the same where it's different for everybody?
It's different for everybody, so you can take it.
Except the regular chest, you can take everything inside.
Oh, nice!
Wow.
Oh my gosh, I'm actually gonna run out of space.
Tomato seeds.
They used to have mimics, but I don't know, maybe it was lagging the server.
It's gone now.
What's a mimic?
Oh, like it would eat you.
Yeah, it's like a freedom, but it's gone now.
And then...
No!
Oh, wait.
Take this.
So, yeah.
I think that's the treasure.
I forgot to tell you important things.
Do you remember the place that we changed the heights?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There is a green portal, and when you go there, it leads to a mirror world from this one.
That one is for resource, so when you get a lot of wood, when you want to get a lot of wood, or dirt, or stuff like that, you can get it from there.
That's so awesome!
So you don't take everything from this world.
If you want to keep the landscape, but you want to get a lot of material from the mirror world, I didn't get all the stuff you need.
That's so smart!
That's so awesome!
Oh my gosh.
And yeah, this place is amazing.
It is!
It was my first time modding Minecraft as well, but I love it so much.
Yeah, I can see why.
Hello!
I think Zen is having connection problems.
Oh!
Yeah, I ran up to her when she was on, and she had that disconnect symbol next to her, and I think that's why she keeps logging in and logging out.
Yeah, she's got connection problems, I think.
Why is that happening to her?
I don't know.
I wish she could join us.
Yeah.
That happened to Heavenly too?
Yeah, Heavenly can't get on anymore.
Really?
Alright, Zen!
Um...
Man!
I think maybe Zen is fine.
Oh, she makes me so mad sometimes.
I think she's fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, the disconnect thing!
I worried for no reason.
What's that?
Oh!
Oh, it's that guy again.
What does this thing do?
What does he do?
This guy.
Oh!
When you find him for like three times, after you find him, he'll be gone.
And after you find him for three times, he'll give you a gift.
Oh!
It's that one guy.
Yeah.
Oh, there he is!
Oh, he's escaping!
He's climbing up!
No, sir!
Sir!
Okay, okay, he's gone again.
We gotta go find him.
But that was the third time!
Third, third, or fourth?
I forgot, but you have to find him for multiple times.
Okay.
Oh, I see him, I see him, I see him!
Right here.
He gave...
something.
What was it?
Take it, take it.
A bundle.
Oh!
Yeah, there's a...
gold blocks in it.
Oh!
Where did it go?
Oh, oh, oh!
I need this one.
Do you want your potatoes back?
No, no, it's okay, I have a lot of potatoes.
Okay, thank you!
Oh, I'm gonna put the mailbox...
Wait, how do I put the mailbox...
Oh, there we go.
Nice!
Cool!
Yeah!
What a cool guy.
Hard to combat...
Yeah, he just kind of shows up randomly.
He really likes Mata's...
dirt house hole.
Oh wait, I heard about that.
He shows up there a lot.
Really?
Yeah.
I wonder why.
Mata, you have someone living in your house.
Oh my gosh, he scared me.
Yeah, someone taking over your house, Mata.
Yeah!
Come back and claim it.
How do we get out of here?
Oh, we go up here.
That's right.
Yeah!
I can't see.
I don't know how I'm climbing.
I don't know how I'm climbing, but I'm climbing.
I don't know how this is happening.
Oh god!
Oh, there we go.
I don't know how that happened.
Careful, careful.
Are you okay?
Did Hennie just fall?
Good, thank you.
What a thrill.
I think I need a spell.
Has Hennie met Hennie Jr. yet?
Wait, what is Hennie Jr.?
Hennie Jr.?
What is a Hennie Jr. dial?
What is that?
What?
I have a Hennie Jr.?
Would you like your corpses back, Mint?
Yeah, I think I missed them.
I can take it.
I can do it for you.
Thank you.
I think you like them more than I do.
Here, I'll stand really close.
Oh.
Thank you.
Here you go.
Something must be sacrificed.
I'll sacrifice this dagger.
You know what?
You have a trash can.
At the bottom.
So if you put your item, you don't need it over there.
Oh.
Yeah.
What?
And then it's gone forever?
Yeah.
Yeah, it'll be gone forever.
You can get it back out.
As long as you don't put something else in the trash can.
Oh.
But if you put something else in there, then it's gone.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Bing bong bing.
Bing bong.
Just keep adding stuff to it.
I don't know what else to add.
I need everything else.
Everything else is precious.
Cook.
We got so many stuff over here.
I know.
Oh no.
Everybody's leaving.
What's happening?
Is there a bee in here?
Oh, it's a bee lamp.
That's so cute.
Yeah.
I can make you one if you want to.
But...
Uh...
So...
Sometimes you might will get some item you don't know how to use it.
Yeah.
And then when you go to the...
When you...
When you're pointing at the item you don't know how to use it and press U, it'll show you the recipe of what can you do with it.
Oh, really?
Wait, you press what?
U.
Yeah.
So you can see it.
With U.
Oh my god.
What?
Oh my god, there's so much.
There is.
Ooh.
Witch's house.
This is so cute.
It is.
Oh, do you want to go to End City?
Do you want to touch a waystone so you can go back anytime you want?
Oh, sure.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh.
She left us, everybody.
Now...
We're just out here.
And then...
Oh, gloomy bear.
There's...
There's a big old gloomy bear.
Um...
There's this house over here.
Oh, there's a waystone here.
This is the kitten hole?
Uh...
She hates us.
She hates us!
Oh.
Huh?
What?
Who hates you?
No, no.
Oh, oh, oh.
Nothing.
Huh?
She's hiding something.
No, no, no, no.
The end.
Is there anything different in here or is it the same as normal?
Oh, it's a lot different.
It's a lot different, too.
It is?
Wait, is it?
A little different.
Not crazy different, I think.
But it's different.
Hmm.
Let's see.
Anything...
Oh, wait, there's trees in here!
There's trees.
End...
Midlands.
What's this?
It's a special kind of tree.
Preem log.
Oh, no.
Everybody keeps crashing.
Is it me?
Am I the problem?
Hiya!
Welcome back!
Did it crash for you, too?
Why are we in the end?
Oh, because I thought she was...
So much happened!
So much happened.
Ah!
What's wrong with him?
Why is he among us?
Oh, man.
So, I think the problem is Zen's house.
Because I crashed, too, when I went near Zen's house.
Oh.
Yeah.
Wait, really?
We went with no problems, though.
Yeah, the first time I went with no problems.
But then when I went again...
What happened to the armor I gave you?
It broke because everybody kills me every five seconds.
No!
I have no more armor.
Because everything breaks.
No!
Sad value.
Everybody kills me every five seconds.
I'm trying to not make eye contact with any of these enemies, but because I know I shouldn't look at them, I want to look at them.
I know.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
This is not the end zone I was trying to take her with.
What's different?
Where did she go?
I don't know.
She's gone.
She left us.
There's some weird Endermen that look like Among Us.
What?
That guy right there.
Oh, yeah.
He attacks on...
You don't need to look at him for him to attack.
If he just sees you, he'll attack you.
Okay, okay.
I think we should go.
Oh, thank you.
So, if you ever want to go to the ender dragon and stuff, it's right here.
What is that?
That's an annoying thing.
Not friend.
Where's the...
Oh, Henya!
Henya!
Hold on.
Come here, Henya.
Oh, no.
How do I pick you guys up?
Help!
Henya!
Come here!
Oh, there you go.
You're on my head now.
How do I get Henya off my head?
Wait, I'm not.
You're on my head for me.
It's okay.
I'll just keep you on my head.
Wait, I don't see you on her head either.
Yeah, I'm not.
You are for me.
What?
It's okay.
I'll just have a pet.
River's having a little bit of trouble, I think.
Yeah, it's a little laggy today.
Wait, is there a way stone here?
Or...
Oh, this way, this way, this way.
I don't know where this way is.
Henya's still on my head.
Wait, where is...
Right here, right here.
Oh, I see it.
It blended in.
Nice.
And portal dial.
It's so cool in here too.
Yeah, but...
It looks a lot different as well.
Yeah, it looks so different.
Oh, I...
Monster Hunter.
I can't...
Wait, you play Monster Hunter?
No, but right now, actually there's a sale on a bunch of Monster Hunter games.
I want to get them.
I'm playing World right now, so if you ever want to play it with me, I'm always available.
Okay, that fixed it.
That fixed it.
You got it?
Yeah, I logged out and logged back in so I could fix it.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Mermaid.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, these are like rainbow candles.
They're cute.
They're really cute.
It is pretty.
I want to steal them.
Do it.
Take it.
Steal it.
No one can stop me.
There's a lot.
There's a lot of places to explore.
If you ever want to, you can.
Names.
So many name tags.
Yeah.
Wowee.
I'm out of space.
I think we should get the good backpack for you.
I'm gonna get it.
That's okay.
Mouse can help you for a prize.
For a prize.
I can give her.
It's okay.
I don't really care about my soul.
Do I have it?
Do they stack?
Man, where was the Henya Lone Shark hospitality?
For me, huh?
Helmet.
What do you mean?
I'm Henya the Generous.
Hi, Henya.
You've been an amazing tour guide.
You've been so nice.
So everything.
Yeah.
You stole my candle.
Henya.
No, no.
She stole my candle.
Everything comes with a price, Addy.
Yep.
Nothing is free, Dayo.
It's okay, Henya.
If you want...
If you need a henchman for your business, I'm here for you.
I thank you that my business is bad, Dayo.
Henya, I built a watermelon for you.
That is true.
It took you seven hours, you said?
It took me seven hours.
Seven hours?
No way.
Oh, wait.
Have you shown her?
Oh yeah, I did.
Do you remember the Curlsprays watermelon?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the watermelon.
Oh my god.
It took a long time.
Very long time.
Super long.
We also made a wall for the mochi house too.
You wanna see it?
Let's go spawn.
Spawn.
Okay, so this way.
This way.
Henya Junior is there?
What the heck?
What is a Henya Junior?
Okay, I need to see the Henya Junior.
When the heck did I get the Henya Junior, Dayo?
Oh, so cute.
Yeah, her place is so cute.
Let's see.
She stole the dirt from my chest, so I gave her the wall of dirt.
You see the square dirt over there?
I gave her a wall of dirt.
Oh, I see it.
Up there, that wall?
Yeah, the huge, yeah.
Wow.
I and I the mouse did it together.
Her place is so fun.
When you go down here...
Yeah, this way, this way.
This way, this way.
This way?
Okay.
There's a...
There's a toilet.
But you can go in the...
Oh.
But you're revving up to use the toilet?
Is that what's going on?
Yeah, I'm revving up to use the toilet.
Okay.
It's okay, I get it.
We all have a little bit of...
Something to get out of there, you know?
There's a gun run on the ceiling.
Oh.
Yeah, there's a gun on the ceiling.
Can you see it?
Yeah, I see him.
Oh.
Hanya.
Hanya, you had one job.
No, no, it's not me.
I think Mochi did it.
I wonder.
Did you just say dang it?
What did I hear from you?
No, no, no, no.
I think Mochi is somewhere.
Do you think she's like, maybe she's invisible?
She pulled the lever?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm pretty sure she did it.
I don't see her on the server.
I don't see her.
They have legs?
What else is in here?
I don't know.
Her place is like a lot of...
You can go a lot of places.
Hmm.
I like the fish tanks.
Oh!
I thought this was a person.
She has security cameras and everything.
Yup.
I'm gonna give her something.
A lot of security cameras over here.
Yeah.
What should I give her?
A lot of stuff.
You know what?
I'll keep everything.
Ew, they walk.
There's a Herobrine again!
Why there's a Herobrine everywhere?
Up there too!
Oh my gosh!
That's terrifying!
I found another one right there!
I've been jumpscared by so many of those.
There's so many of them!
Oh, I see them right there!
It's really realistic looking.
It's in here too!
Do you see them?
Oh my god.
Where?
Up there.
Over here.
Over here, right?
Right here, right here.
No, no, no.
Stand right here.
And look that way.
I see them.
On the wall, right?
Uh...
I think you're looking at the different direction.
There's more?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I see them!
Wow!
Where are they?
Scary though.
Scary!
Why I can't see in here?
I think this is her mining area?
I don't know.
Maybe, yeah.
Can't see out anywhere in here.
Water!
I'm lost?
Oh, water!
Haha!
I'm just gonna drop down.
Oh, never mind.
Oh!
Oh, it's all the...
Oh, she has a limpid too!
Oh yeah, she has a limpid too!
What's this?
She got a lot of stuff.
Yeah.
Fish tank.
Wait, I don't see any genie here.
Where is that?
Prismarite?
Yeah, where's Henea junior?
Wait!
Four skins?
Four skins...
skin.
Henea junior?
Four skin junior.
So many!
There's just so many...
Is she a nature over here?
Okay.
Why are there so many?
She got the Henea junior at the dome.
Is this it?
No, fourth...
This way.
Up here?
She got the beautiful dorm as well.
No, not this way.
This is definitely a meaty place, yeah.
I think so too.
She also has a little man.
Wow!
Look at it!
Oh my goodness!
This table is so good!
The axolotls are all so many different colors.
Who is that?
What is this?
Who is that, you guys?
Who is that?
Is it black?
No!
I'm scared!
It's mint!
No, it's black!
What?
Thank you!
Thank you, Ari!
What's gun run?
Gun run!
Oh my god, these are alive!
Oh my god!
Haruka junior?
Ari junior, fruit junior, Kuro junior, Giga junior, Matan junior, Dusclap junior, Iron mouse junior, Heavenly junior, Sushi junior, Joel junior, Is there, is there, Hennya junior maybe in here?
Maybe in here?
Hennya junior!
Oh no, it's just Hennya!
Huh?
Hennya junior!
Right here, right here!
Where's, where's my junior?
He's right...
here.
If you look, here, here, here.
Right there, right there.
Hennya junior!
Did I eat it?
Oh, did you eat yourself?
No, no, of course not, of course not.
I will never, I will never.
Is that germa?
Gingerbread picnic.
Please don't eat it.
Is this germa?
We can eat them?
Thank goodness I didn't eat them.
Oh.
During the picnic?
That's so cute.
This germa...
On the other side?
What's this?
Germa-san.
Germa?
Germa-san?
Germa-san.
Yeah, I think he's on the wall.
Oh, really?
Yeah, right here.
Huh?
Wait, that's a germa-san?
I think so.
Oh, everybody talking about him.
But I never know what does he look like.
Now I see him.
Germa-san!
Now you know.
No, it's a different people.
What's this?
That's not germa.
What?
I will never know what germa-san look like.
Maybe it's this one.
Over here.
They say it's black though.
Oh, yeah.
My chat told me that's black.
It's his brother?
Wait, really?
Oh, he has brother?
That's wonderful.
That's right.
He's so popular.
Nice.
Germa-san.
People keep talking about Germa-san.
One day I will see him.
One day.
One day, one day.
He has brother?
That's cool.
His gingerbread is so cute.
Yeah.
Oh, is this the room?
Who is this?
It's a dog.
I love her kitchen.
That looks so cute.
This place is kind of crazy.
It's kind of crazy.
Crazy.
I like it.
Are you okay?
What the heck?
Oh.
Why do so many dogs live here?
I think she's obsessed.
I think so.
Hi, boss.
See you.
Hello.
Hi, boss.
No, she keeps the fox in the cage.
What is this?
A turtle?
I don't know.
What is that?
I don't think it's a turtle.
A dinosaur?
A little dinosaur?
Little baby dinosaur.
A little baby dinosaur trapped in here, though.
So sad.
That's abuse.
I'm reporting her.
Oh, and a smoking bird.
Yeah, she gets a smoking bird.
Robin.
It's not good for you.
Don't smoke.
That's why Robin is dying.
Stop smoking.
Yeah, stop smoking.
Stop dying smoking.
Smoking hot bird?
I don't know.
I don't know about that.
Stevie, hot kiddo in your area.
Whoa.
It's starting to lag a little bit.
It's okay.
This was so fun.
Yeah.
I hope you enjoy it.
There's a lot of places you can enjoy here.
I really hope we can have fun together again soon.
Yeah.
I will have to find a place to make my home.
Oh, yeah.
Do you have any places you want to make it?
I don't know.
Maybe next to your house.
Maybe under your house.
Above your house.
In your house.
You want to see what's under my house?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to make you TP sword.
There she goes.
I'm going to make a house inside her house.
Under her house.
Above her house.
Let's accept.
Welcome to my basement.
Wow.
It's huge.
Yeah.
I'm going to place a lot of chest down here.
So I can place everything I want.
Oh, yeah.
You already started.
Yeah.
I am.
This is the inventory.
This is the same thing Mousy had.
It's the same one.
I believe.
I need to place more.
Zen is coming here.
Zen.
Zen, what are you doing?
I tried to steal my stuff again.
Oh.
Zen.
We're so fast.
She ran away.
Did she steal my stuff?
Manga.
What's this?
But yeah.
Once you have a chest down here.
And you connect with those.
Like a cable.
And this one.
The connector in the terminal.
And you're ready to go.
It's like moving.
You have so many sticks.
I do.
Wow.
Okay.
I'm gonna learn from you.
I'm gonna build a huge place.
That's gonna have every inventory item ever.
If you ever have a question about the Minecraft.
I'll help you as I can.
Okay.
Thank you.
Of course.
I'm not gonna take anything.
Oh thank you.
Because everybody who took my stuff.
They ended up dead.
Oh.
By your hands or?
I don't know.
It just happened.
I'm not gonna take anything.
I don't wanna end up dead.
By...
By Hanya killing me.
Who would want that?
Yeah.
You're not stealing anything, right?
No.
I'm looking at all the things that...
That the game has to offer.
Yeah.
I'm not taking a single thing.
Chat, is she stealing my stuff?
No.
You were such a nice...
You were such a nice tour guide.
Why would I steal anything?
Yeah.
Stop touching me.
I'm on the way back here.
Oh my god.
I forgot that I set my spawn point.
Spawn.
Is she at the entrance?
I'm here.
Welcome back.
Welcome back, Dayo.
Thank you.
Here.
I'll give you your energy.
Take back.
Thank you for the egg.
No happy birthday.
None.
No life.
I also have like a...
Well, I think a lot of people took it.
So you can take an iron chest if you want to.
Iron armor.
Oh, thank you.
I might take it.
Yeah.
But also Mousy gave me a lot of diamond.
I think I'll make diamond armor.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
I'll be more powerful.
So yeah.
There's a lot of places.
There's a lot of places and a lot of people in here.
I hope you'll enjoy it.
Yeah.
Thank you, Hanya.
Thank you for giving me the tour today.
Of course.
Anytime.
Yeah.
I would love to play Minecraft with you more.
Because always I wanted to.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll find a place to build.
And...
I'll play.
Yes.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Anything you need, please let me know.
Okay.
For a price, right?
Oh, no.
Not for me.
Really?
Yeah.
I wish I could crouch right now.
Here.
I can do this.
Hanya-sama.
Oh, no.
You're so kind.
You're so genius.
You're so beautiful.
You're so kind.
You're so wonderful.
Well, if you ask me, I can give you anything.
But if you steal, I'm going to...
Yeah.
Okay.
I won't steal.
Yeah.
No steal.
When you do...
That sounds horrible.
Something will happen.
That sounds like... I don't wish that upon anybody.
That sounds like...
I don't wish that upon anybody.
Yeah.
Why would you steal?
Just ask her.
Yeah.
Of course.
Okay.
I'm going to go talk to my chat now, Hanya.
Thank you for hanging out with me.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'll see you later.
I'll see you later, too.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
Let
me...
I forgot to say bye to Mousy.
Let me go say bye to Mousy.
And then to...
One second.
Oh.
Bye, Mousy.
Thank you.
Bye, Zen.
The mouse is...
Is...
Is AFK.
But maybe she'll see it.
And we can steal stuff while riding.
Oh my gosh.
That sounds awesome.
If I steal something, she'll ruin my life?
Oh yeah.
Baby.
That sounds like the best thing ever.
You got braver with your mask?
It's because she couldn't see my pervert smile.
Why does this fit on my head so well?
Why does this fit on my head actually so well?
So perfectly?
Oh.
Maybe not perfect-perfect.
But it feels like my head was made to wear panties.
There we go!
Oh, I just needed to make it a little bit smaller.
Perfect!
Your head is the size of Hena's butt.
Dang, she's got a big butt.
So I guess I have to find a place to build a house in there.
Oh gosh, there's so many... oh, wait, hold on, I'm a little...
It's a little wobbly.
There's so many people that joined the server.
I've never met Ari before, Froggy before, but they were so nice.
And I'm nervous about meeting new people, but...
I will do my best.
To be social!
I'll do my best!
I can't believe you're wearing Hena's panties.
She gave them to me for this purpose!
You can take that mask off now.
The rest of the team can't see you.
What do you mean, the team?
It was hot in there.
Thanks for the guide.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, I think also...
The...
What's it called?
All the mods?
There's so much to be able to...
Ah, it's a pervert!
There's so much to...
Create.
This shoujo server was amazing.
Modern Minecraft is completely different.
By the way, nice hentai common cosplay.
Thank you!
Mint, what are your thoughts on dog-dog?
Oh no, don't get me started about dog-dog.
Dog-dog.
Don't get me started about saying dog-dog.
Because once I start saying dog-dog, I won't stop saying dog-dog.
Over and over, I just gotta be compelled to say dog-dog.
If I start saying dog-dog, I can't stop saying dog-dog.
I just gotta keep saying dog-dog.
I still prefer vanilla Minecraft.
I think both have its good things, right?
Because I think the one thing, if I could turn it off about the v-shojo server, while it's convenient.
But you know, dying and losing your stuff is part of the thrill, you know?
So, it's part of the thrill.
But...
You know...
If I...
I think for this, it seems very much more like...
Like...
What's the word?
Building stuff.
Because there's so many pretty mods to like customize your house and things like that.
They kill each other a lot.
That makes sense too then, you know?
It's also what makes new players quit often.
I guess if you join a server...
And...
And people are always...
There's a lot of PvP.
Then, you know.
There were so many graves.
I believe it.
But that was so fun.
Oh, I turned off my music earlier.
That was so fun.
I hope you guys enjoyed the tour as well.
HENYA was so awesome for...
For giving us such a nice tour.
And...
I hope you guys liked it.
There's a raid, but I can't read it.
Oh my god.
I can't...
Oh my gosh, I can't read it.
I can't read it.
I'm so sorry, but thank you for the raid.
Not to mention booby traps.
Yeah.
The white on white is so bad.
It is.
Salve.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
YouTube turned pinned messages white as...
No.
No way.
What's my secret?
Oh wait.
You didn't tell me that.
The text was...
Was black.
The text
was black.
Oh my god, you guys.
Making me look like a...
Damn clown.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
Issues that Zen is in the server, so there's that.
I think the prison thing, that was really cool.
I liked that.
Tego, thanks for a month.
Thank you so much.
Sorry I couldn't read people's super chats and stuff while they were happening, but thank you very much, everybody.
Thanks for all the gifted.
Thank you for watching.
Thank you for donating.
Thank you for super chatting.
Thank you.
Can anyone read it though?
It'd be cool to know.
Exploring dungeons with friends is always fun.
I think also the...
The gacha with the...
I mean, I guess...
Chests are always gacha.
But I also really like that...
That each one can be taken...
Like...
Each person has a different stuff in the special chest.
It's so cool.
Wait, a month already?
Hell yeah!
Doc, thank you!
The prisoner area was a mod that's based on dead cells.
Along with the weapons as well.
Okay, that's what...
Yeah, yeah, that's what Henya was saying earlier too, right?
Oh my gosh, I...
I'm so happy that I got...
Henya and Maus to help me go around.
And Maus was giving...
Oh my gosh, the Dejiko hat!
When I saw her wearing it, I was like...
That looks so much like a Dejiko hat.
But maybe it's just a cat hat.
But...
It was a Dejiko hat.
It was so cute.
And...
And then Henya getting the Puchiko hat.
And this...
Yeah, her cinnamon rolls!
So sweet!
Mausie helping out was so awesome.
Oh, let me...
Thank you both so much.
And Ahri coming with us.
It was so fun.
The real question is...
Why do they all have dungeons in their basements?
That's just, you know...
Standard...
V-Shojo protocol, you know?
What was I gonna say?
Fab, I see this!
Thanks for a month!
I have to...
I have to figure out what I'm...
What I want my house to be like.
I think...
The most...
The most intimidating thing is like...
With all the mods, I'm like...
You know...
I'm not used to having so many more...
More options for building.
So...
I have to get used to it.
I think.
So we're glad to see you going around the V-Shojo server.
Can't wait to see you.
Meet more new people and have fun on there.
Thank you!
Make a maid cafe house?
I was thinking that.
Yeah, there's like a million different blocks.
The world is our oyster.
Haunted maid cafe?
Why do you think I was collecting corpses, huh?
Why do you think I was collecting corpses?
I wonder if there are ghosts in the mod though.
Like little wisps?
I wonder if there's wisps.
Make Shadow Moses Island.
You know...
First of all...
Tenya making a Raiden reference was not on my bingo list for tonight.
But also...
With the...
With the extra blocks and everything, it might even be possible to make...
To make wrecks.
Yeah, there's even RGB blocks.
Pretty sure even one of the builder mods adds over 4000 new blocks.
Net cafe wrecks?
I'm gonna have to figure out what to build.
And I want to explore.
I feel like maybe...
A lot of the server has been explored already.
But that's okay too.
With create, you can make a function wrecks I bet.
Oh my god.
That would be...
That would be so insane.
That's insane.
There's still a lot to see?
I'm excited.
Minto is streaming this late?
Yeah, it is pretty late, huh?
And I streamed late last night too.
But we're just finishing up and I'm...
I'm actually getting...
I think I have all my social energy...
All my social energy is...
It just disappeared.
And when social energy disappears...
My energy disappears.
I also become just a tiny wisp.
It's hard to keep this form.
It's hard to keep this form when I...
When I become so sleepy.
But...
The VSHojo girls are always in contact with Tofu.
So if you want something added, you can ask.
Oh, yes!
The way I got added to the server was I joined some Discord.
Actually, I was having technical issues with Minecraft just this morning.
Or last night when I was trying to get in.
So I also was like...
Tofu!
Help meee!
I don't know Tofu, but they were very nice.
Not even Mouse has explored the whole server yet?
Okay!
Leave it to me!
We'll go on a grand adventure!
We'll go on a grand adventure in the server.
The server seems so friendly.
Have you heard that the Metal Gear Solid board game drops this month?
If we get it, I wonder if we'll get a hand cam playthrough with Matara.
That's a great idea!
I pre-ordered it!
I pre-ordered it when they first announced it, so...
We can see if that can be arranged.
Yeah, thanks for the idea.
Okay.
Does it have spoilers?
No, it's only...
It's only Metal Gear Solid 1.
I believe.
Oh, let me exit out of Minecraft.
I think it's...
Goodbye.
Hold on, let me...
One second...
We'll go to the maid cafe.
I'm lagging a little bit though.
Recently, my computer has been acting so funky.
Like...
Wait,
where are you guys?
What?
Where did you guys go?
We're dead!
There's nothing on the menu.
I missed the last bit of Ghost Trick, but wanted to mention after I finished it, I was so floored I had to immediately drop everything and go buy a Sizzle plushie from Etsy.
Thanks again for introducing the game.
Of course!
Glad you liked it as much as I did.
One second...
Okay, there you are looking bulky.
There we go.
It's dark.
I missed most of the stream, but are you excited to build?
I am!
I am, I am.
There was something I was going to say.
Oh!
Oh my god.
My um...
Recently, I was like trying to search for something on my computer.
Like you know how like when you go to the start menu and you search for something?
But like I would go to search and it would just like...
Stop.
It would like...
The menu would disappear.
It was so weird.
I've been having some weird issues with my computer lately.
Hopefully...
Hopefully it's okay.
Hm...
Mine stream...
Mine stream?
Minecraft stream...
Are back!
Maybe...
I don't wanna...
I don't want to, um...
I still am trying to think about a way to do...
A...
A Memble.
But I also realized...
Um...
I guess this sounds kind of mean, but if someone stops being a membu, if they still had access to the server, to the Minecraft server, it wouldn't be very fair.
So I'm still trying to figure out how exactly to do it.
But I also still want... not a modern Minecraft, like a vanilla one too, maybe.
Give us the fushoujo server keys.
Oh yeah, totally.
Make it hardcore for giggles.
Change the password every month.
I guess that's a good idea.
You can change the password every month.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, that's a smart idea, you guys.
See?
I'm glad I brought it up with you guys.
Michi just DMed me.
She said, Mint, you're in the Minecraft server now.
But yeah.
It's the username whitelist feature.
Much safer.
Maybe.
I don't know.
There's lots of... there's some ways we can do it.
I just have to... get around to doing it.
Since you love ghost trick, can I recommend a PS2 game called Shadow of Destiny?
You... you...
You... you... you... you play as a guy who uses time travel to stop his own murder.
That sounds so familiar to what we just played.
Let's play together.
Yeah!
Can't wait to play Minecraft though.
I can't wait to play Minecraft with people though.
The server seems so active.
I'm so happy.
Oh, I'm so happy.
Seems so active.
Thanks for Minecraft stream.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I am going to go to sleep now.
Oh my gosh.
She's inviting me back on the server.
I think I'm gonna go to sleep though.
More fun with friends.
Yeah!
Lots of Minto, everybody!
Thank you so much for watching and hanging out.
Sorry that I wasn't able to... wasn't able to... read chat so much.
But I appreciate you guys hanging out with me and watching and all the fun stuff.
So, I hope you guys like the tour as well.
I'll see you guys... oh, tomorrow will be...
I think 3 p.m.
EST.
Still not sure what I'm doing.
I'll have a waiting room up tonight.
Yeah, I'll figure it out.
Okay.
Otsumita!
Thank you, thank you!
Have a good day, have a good night.
And stay hydrated.
And all that fun stuff.
Itterashai!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye!
See you!